oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
all right what's up everybody i am
thomas dopasiola whatever you want to
call me welcome back to another episode
of the dope as usual podcast we are here
to talk about life problems drugs
accomplishments and everything in
between today guys we have a very
special guest and if you know me
personally and i haven't said it to you
yet i'm [ __ ] excited i'm trying to
keep it down till we start uh brian
callum comedian brian kell thank you for
coming it's good to be here brother
before i even start i'm just i know
marty so like uh
matt i'm just gonna hop into it i'm
[ __ ] mad tv fanatic since the day it
came out
and i told my mom who's the guest my
mom's she's in the chat right now oh is
that right she's so [ __ ] active on it
um
i saw brian county just [ __ ] cabana
boys come and go what the [ __ ] mom yes
that's exactly what i said when he's
like i used to get fan mail from jail on
that man
guys and girls oh bro my buddy jimmy
we're with him and his girl it was after
i don't remember some kind of a parade
and he goes come on in here we go into a
gay bar on in the 20s in chelsea or
something
and he his girlfriend myself i think it
was just the three of us
and i was elvis in that bar i was elvis
i never get recognized from that tv but
somehow in that gay bar i was the [ __ ]
and i was [ __ ] loving it i was the
only straight guy in the room of course
but you're the only straight guy that
everyone's like i wish i won that guy i
was gonna say i would have been i would
be the coolest guy yeah you would have
literally been elvis yeah it's a weird
that character was so [ __ ] weird um i
i gotta ask the first time you did it
were you like yo do i gotta wear this
for real or were you i was the one who
said we should put me in a blonde wig
and high-heeled sneakers you know and i
and i and i was like and i want to just
be a dumb i only all i said was i just
want to be i want a super dumb pool boy
i don't even know if i was perfect yeah
i don't even know if i said pool boy but
whatever it was because the writers were
amazing so i always take very little
credit for what i did on that show but
i remember i pitched the idea i remember
dave herman who's hilarious steve herman
office space dave vermont yes
and dave herm good call dude wow that
was very good and he
started laughing because i was like i
just want to do a character who is like
it's hot
yeah just a guy who says dumb [ __ ] like
man
this is it's hot here you know he just
started laughing like that's so dumb and
i was like that's all i know and then
they just kind of started writing stuff
and i sort of we put it together is it
improv when you guys are just trying to
make a character well
when you write sketch comedy whether
it's saturday night live matt tv or
whatever it's so the process laborious
because you'll get into fights over
whether monkey or [ __ ] is a funnier
word you know depending on the concept
it's not just one person yeah and then
people are like well it's got one too
many beats it should end here and it's
like it's one too many jokes and be like
what and it just gets weird man you're
you're pitching your idea and they're
dissing you behind your back it's a
nasty place sketch
because do you get to write your own
stuff on that yeah i tried but this oh
the writers were so good dude they were
so good i didn't even need to you know
that show came out i remember when it
came out i used to watch
mad tv and then at 10 30 my dad was like
no we're watching [ __ ] oh no it's
america's most wanted mad tv and then a
10 30 saturday night live came on so my
dad like would change it i'd go to the
other room like
[ __ ] no i'm not watching sarah it was
too yeah
no thank you at the when i was that age
you know what i'm saying like i [ __ ]
loved it but i think i stopped watching
when i started doing drugs that's really
what happened because i wasn't home on
saturday night no more right was i'm
[ __ ] getting [ __ ] up with my
friends yeah matt when you do those
shows like you don't know what's gonna
happen it's like when i did the hangover
like you don't know they're going to be
sensations you don't know they're going
to last that long you don't know they're
going to be part of
the american culture yeah you know what
i mean and then a whole generation of
people especially
latino people and black people really
that's who was the main audience man it
was tv and people say well it's an urban
audience that means black and brown
that's exactly what it means that's not
you know it isn't white was it really
yeah man it was if there was something
about about you know when when arne lane
got arrested and he did this character
called my white mama we did a lot of
characters that's my white mama yeah i
say that
i quoted that to my [ __ ] girlfriend
the other day yeah she doesn't get it
he's [ __ ] are you laughing just like
a little parker's genius and he
he got arrested and so he was in like
like
basically i don't know not general
lockup but like he was in the jail
county county jail and he was chained to
a gang dude who was had stab wounds in
his back
this mexican guy and
he was like man they [ __ ] were like
yo my wife mama and everybody in that
[ __ ] jail knew
it was just that was the show
that that
black and brown people watched they
didn't watch saturday night live
saturday night live was made
by white people
for white people it was it was like
esoteric and it was like i get that
if you think about the people that were
the standouts it was all white and they
just didn't really
mesh with or connect if you look at men
tv it was like orlando jones deborah
wilson you
well yeah phil lamar so three of the
cast members were black
so it was just different and it wasn't
it was just it was just different man i
don't know i don't know what it was i
don't take any credit for that of course
but but that that that was a cool show
man it's kind of funny that you say that
because every kid at my school was like
did you watch zoomed tv and they're all
[ __ ] brown yeah so that does make
sense again
yeah you gotta be walking down the
street and these like just
hard hard looking dudes like black dudes
in new york city like with gold teeth
and the kind of guys a lot of white
people are like oh that group of black
guys looks like they're trouble you know
and they'd see me and be like oh [ __ ]
i'd get hugged and grabbed and it was
[ __ ] awesome i was like i'm i'm like
an og here it was really cool so that
that was that was when i knew that it
was something different man how many
years were you on there i was on i was
in the first two that's eight episodes i
was in i was in the original cast wait
wait that was 26 years ago you were only
26 years ago young man that's true
because i was six years old twenty-six
five twenty-five years ago that was when
i was on mad tv wow yeah yeah didn't
feel like it no it doesn't how do you
think hey how do you think you feel like
go back like yeah [ __ ] command boy
eat a dick yeah [ __ ] yeah that's like yo
good [ __ ] yeah man i used to watch it
constantly man so i that's one of the
first things i had to bring up it's the
first i [ __ ] love it so damn fun
so you're only on there for the first
two yeah that's how is that possible i
don't know why do i feel like i remember
way more than that
well you know they played a lot they
would just always play different you
know so question i always wondered when
you're filming the skit show do you guys
film everything in one day and then put
and just play it all at once no because
we would do spoofs on movies and all
that so that would be a hole
so you're working all the time yeah
i you know you want to hear the secret i
never liked acting no i've never been on
a set where i didn't want to go home
what really too much work man oh i don't
i like i work hard but
um
when you see how a film or a tv show
shot
when you see how much time like on mad
tv when you had to be in prosthetics
when they would paint glue on your face
and plaster the [ __ ] on your face and
you'd be wearing contacts and you were
wearing the mold of someone's face like
arnold schwarzenegger's when i when i
came back as the terminator to save
jesus bro i was in that i was in that
face mask for 17 hours you start to go
crazy
you start to go crazy were you doing
no
i wasn't my mistake rogan used to always
say do stand up i was like nah i'm on tv
now big mistake oh didn't you do stephen
cigar i feel yes i did this
yes i did i didn't know that yeah bro
see that's why i'm like no there was
more than just the two that's oh i did a
lot of that that's what's got me
circling back because then will castle
took over the [ __ ] well he's a genius
he took over arnold schwarzenegger and
everything he's one of my best friends
that dude's a genius he's you want to
talk about the back in many ways and i
really and i've been doing this now
for 27 years i mean in la i've worked
with a lot of big people
i think the most talented person i've
ever met in my [ __ ] life
is
is there are three people that i think
are the funniest people ever i'm very
curious will sasso can do everything he
can do everything he can act
like dramatically he can do he's the
best impressionist of all time he's so
[ __ ] no one can do what he does he's
so good he can do original characters no
one can do what he does he's he's i've
never seen anybody that good in my life
and oh by the way he can improv with the
very best of him and he's he's just
astonishing he's a dust
he does he's done stand up he's opened
up on my shows and still crushes he
plays a character he wears a wig [ __ ]
he's he's a genius he's a [ __ ] genius
that's why 10 minute podcast was so
funny
and that was his idea it was funnier
without the video because you guys are
so good at improv yes the fact that it
was just audio actually made it he's
been preaching that ten minutes since
the damage me crystal and will sasso one
night we're making each other laugh so
[ __ ] hard and we got recognized and
will gets nervous when he gets
recognized there's a bunch of young
people huge and i pushed him in like i
pushed him he walked he had to walk back
in and get his hat or something and it
was at uh it was at canters i think that
oh yeah yeah an exact word south and
there were always people sitting there
and i push them back in and i go i'm
will sasso and i'm famous and he [ __ ]
like he's like you [ __ ] but
anyway we were laughing so hard the
whole night we were just doing bit after
bit after bit and will just called me
and chris and goes i think we should do
a podcast and i go all right we'll do an
hour podcast and he goes i don't think
so i think he should be the 10-minute
possibility so genius well he's a genius
so ahead of his time will sasso already
lang
when i when he was on mad tv artie lang
was the funniest and the second funniest
dude just off the cuff natural like the
lebron james right like just the natural
athletes he's a funny [ __ ] yeah
a beast and zach galifianakis those
truly those are my three funniest people
ever
like
he's a funny [ __ ]
i mean i've seen his i don't know why he
doesn't do stand-up anymore but he was
the one he did when he just playing
piano was [ __ ] funny monster i
thought it was hilarious but my favorite
all-time mad tv i've talked about it on
this show months ago is will sasso
playing elvis with michael mcdonald yeah
but the hot dog and the and i know all
the words i'm just saying that's the
that's one of the funniest things i've
ever seen in my whole [ __ ] life
forever i just put i put thomas on to
the uh bully the will sasso bully
3d bit where he's like bullying you out
of your own shirt again a lot of that
was his making he just you know i mean
he's amazing
he was like the [ __ ] giant dog in the
little dog from the cartoons like yo
stop picking on him but it's funny yeah
exactly stop [ __ ] with them
unbelievable
unbelievable so those are your three
favorite people three funniest people
you ever missed you know when you've
been doing comedy for so long some
people it's just astonishing
of course of course because like you
said it's all it's all around yeah
you're telling me you don't like acting
or you don't like being on set though i
like acting i just the set life where
you shoot one page a day the
the slow process the getting there at
five in the morning you know the 16
hours the i don't like it i never have i
never have the only the only thing i
liked about acting was if i had a cast
that i liked and i could caught up with
and be a silly goose with yeah otherwise
it's just it's weird work i love plays i
love stand-up that's where i get my
acting that's where i get acting kind of
really interferes with everything else
you do too in the sense that when you go
to film you can't really podcast on a
schedule you can't go on the road on the
schedule there is a movie that that they
kind of somebody wants me for that i'm
actually intrigued by though it might be
good cool yeah i don't want to say what
it is yet but it could be good so we'll
see i mean i look i mean i i i
i'll probably say yes you know to
whatever i get you know depends
i say this [ __ ] i have a love hate
relationship i'm dramatic it's it's it's
i say a lot of [ __ ] i don't know i feel
you sometimes it's like when he's gonna
work [ __ ] i hope they can so i hope they
don't when they're [ __ ] i used to
moving yeah god i got up at four i hope
they don't even open the door going to
sleep in the truck right i just pray
that people cancel
that's my whole life for real i i know
dude really sucks the hardest thing is
like not
wanting to just quit everything
like like sometimes you just get
tired like it's tiring bro isn't it like
the hustle
never ends
if you stop hustling in this business
we'll see you later you're [ __ ] so you
gotta you know but you've got to stay
inspired i think that for anybody who's
young the biggest thing is to stay
inspired two things tell the truth
to yourself like live honestly which
nobody does and and stay inspired find
find the why
you got to you got to find the why it's
so important i think outdoing yourself i
think is a big motivation i love that i
love when i go i [ __ ] crushed it good
[ __ ] well that's like when you when you
imagine your best self and you strive
for it like who is the best version of
me
oh that [ __ ] don't do drugs he
gets up at five
[ __ ] that guy
i don't know maybe
maybe i always say that about myself but
then again like
my faults
are also the reason i'm funny
i don't know like my dis my deep
self-loathing
is one of the reasons
i think it's all funny people yeah bro
making fun of yourself is the funniest
thing you could possibly do do you like
people that do so let me ask you would
you rather be around somebody who
doesn't like themselves or somebody who
loves themselves doesn't like themselves
right it's funny it's more interesting
it's always funny they're compensating
for [ __ ] you know what i'm saying like
like you like i i tell the story i've
told a thousand times i'll tell a
thousand one i'm an acting class and
jeffrey tambor is like this amazing
actor and he goes you got you got a
little self-esteem problem and this
famous actor in the back goes thank god
everybody looks back and he goes well he
wouldn't be funny if he liked himself
and i never forgot that i was like damn
i've heard that so many times i'm gonna
stick to well like any time you hear
great people especially artists writers
and actors and directors and
you know
they all are and that this includes
anybody really that except for some
athletes but even that
most of them are motivated by their own
profound sense of inadequacy self-doubt
is what all the greats
have and i don't care what anybody says
i really don't i can see that well like
trying to outdo yourself like you doubt
it let me try to do it i
i guess even the story about jesus on
the cross right like not to get too
crazy
go i gotta you know what i'm saying like
not to get too deep but like even jesus
had his doubts on the cross and finally
he was like is it worth it because he
was like yeah he goes why have you
forsaken me he's like he's yelled at god
and then finally he said it's it is
accomplished right so in other words he
got his second wind is what i'm hearing
yeah
i mean i guess [ __ ] it that would be one
of the symbols of the suffering on the
cross the idea of i love the way you
loop back together [ __ ] dude i'll bring
it back to hardcore christian [ __ ]
i ain't even a christian i'll get
religious i'm jesus christ barney went
to a catholic school and didn't believe
in god my dad was that way my dad went
to the seminary and he was like wait a
minute i don't believe in jesus anymore
i was like well all right there you go
i did i didn't grow up religious not
really i mean i've been in church once i
i do believe but but i i yeah i believe
you might not know brian was born
overseas he grew up all over the world
before circling back to right really
where he moved i didn't move to the
states i was 14. oh [ __ ] did you get to
get philippines india lebanon pakistan
lebanon again
saudi arabia yeah oh [ __ ] that's
sounds cool and shitty at the same time
it was good man it was cool yeah i loved
it what were you doing as a kid you're
only there for every once what eight
months yeah what like a year and a half
yeah you you don't really put that on
your roots it does have its issues you
pretend to be a different kind of person
in each place yeah that's probably why i
became an actor because you know i'm a
comedian because you know you make
people laugh and just be kind of good at
sports you know just so you're not the
last guy picking on the team that's how
you make friends went to oregon it's a
good basis
yeah i guess i'll try to make people
laugh and i don't got no weed or friends
this sucks right when you move well you
move to another country at 14. bro my
dad would come home and be like guess
what say bye to the dog we're going to
[ __ ] start
like dogs saudi arabia i don't know what
that is i'm in greece i just made
friends again i thought dude it's been a
year and a half i'm finally getting my
stride get it let's go you know it's not
his fault but that was his you speak a
bunch of different languages
he said no
[Laughter]
in broken english
how many languages you said
fluently which is not true but it just
sounds good i mean i gotta be honest you
can say enough to make you think you can
exactly you can say about two sentences
i'm like damn i go to frank i got a
friend i was just in france and i
butchered i butchered the language
but i speak you know the americans
thought it was good you know you know
you suck at french when they answer you
back in english no matter
you know you're [ __ ] brown and [ __ ]
don't speak spanish
yes there's a computer store just if you
go down i'm like
yes just go down there and you know you
can
i speak english
the worst thing is being brown not
speaking spanish oh bro they might as
well just attack me with their eyes i
was gonna say dude thomas infamously was
taught how to speak spanish partially by
his white supremacist stepfather my
mom's dumbass married some [ __ ] white
supremacists legitimate ass dudes i've
been to the prisons my whole life
visiting this guy oh really yes oh wait
[ __ ] dog your mom married a white
supremacist my mom is a [ __ ] brown
lady but she looks white and my grandma
was jewish and like a jewish polish lady
but my grandpa's mexican but my mom
decided my jewish family my mom married
some [ __ ] white supremacist ass dude
i didn't know he was until he took his
shirt off went what the [ __ ] does that
mean he had swastikas or what
i can't get into everything but there
were swazikas there was the bolts there
was white is right there was damn dude
it was a lot it was weird so he spent a
lot of time he's there now oh he's there
now yeah they got divorced when i was
like
15. okay but he taught me spanish and
he's a white supremacist did you did you
retain it did you was he cool to you
he's [ __ ] awesome oh he was he was
the
he was cooler than my dad was to me wow
my dad wasn't my dad was like on drugs
when i was a kid but
he taught me everything he taught me how
to live wage taught me how to he was a
[ __ ] genius at like 30 [ __ ]
degrees
but he had so many felonies that he was
just
what happened just doing crimes um he
was before the three strikes law
so he went to prison uh
18th birthday they put him right in the
thing it's a long story but
when they broke up he was like hey i'm
going to tell you this thing he's
telling me all the people he murdered
and weird [ __ ] is that a gang
the white supremacist gang whatever that
the [ __ ] is
nation or something like that i never
asked man yeah but i know like when we'd
be on the outside gas stations certain
fools would come up to him and say
things and he would just do some little
hand and then just
all right and back up yeah it's very odd
sounds like he was connected dude oh for
sure
there's a lot of [ __ ] i can't ever talk
about but i've told you
there's been some wild instance with
that guy and i'm the brown kid a little
fat brown okay with this white
supremacist blonde hair
blue eye [ __ ] shredded tatted monster
oh really you got any pictures
i'll show you after all right yeah yeah
he i showed he sounded a little gay too
do you have any pictures
oh shredded huh is he shredded no um
that that there are some dudes there are
some real [ __ ] huh you know and
i mean when you see them you know
i i have a very good eye for meth heads
and prisoners i saw i saw a couple
mongols the other day the the biker gang
dudes oh oh yeah we got some stories
about that oh bro they're scary look
they're cool as long as you're cool yeah
accept all races that's [ __ ] scary
dude i never considered that biker gangs
aren't on necessarily like some racial
um well
a lot of them are i think they were i
think the hells angels didn't allow or
they didn't they didn't take in
nobody else latin they're only white
guys
so the mongols i think were started
because of that i don't know yeah i saw
some when i told you that crazy [ __ ]
that went down at the rainbow room i saw
some crazy [ __ ] pop off and there was
giant mexicans giant white dudes all
with like mongols
jackets they're [ __ ] scary i'm good
yeah they're outlaws bro
well they're tough
they're legit tough dudes like everybody
walks around like a tough guy that's
your life when you when you live that
hard when you live like it's life and
death it's jail for life or like they
take real risks i don't know much about
them but i mean you know you see it on
them you see it on some dudes like you
see it yeah you can feel it uh yeah like
shoulders and restaurants yeah like you
see so many people on the road too that
it's like especially like consider how
many faces have you seen in the past six
years i can pick it up man like you like
when you see an uh like an operator one
of those special forces tip of the
spirit operators those dudes who've done
it all you just see it on their bodies
man you see it on how yeah it's a
presence yeah especially with prisoners
and [ __ ]
there's they're spartans perfect way to
put it yeah [ __ ] yeah exactly
scary man seals those guys they're those
are men
those are those are spartans those did
you see in movies yeah they they're more
comfortable in war
i'm not that way they're they're the
they're the uh
they're the they're the the mongols the
barbarians they are the they are
yeah they're they're the extreme version
of male right it's like what is that
there was a movie where they said their
human beings descended from bonobos and
chimps
right two different two different
strains of ape bonobos solve everything
with sex
and chimps solve everything with
violence
and there are some if you if you see if
you so so in the san diego zoo and
something a lot of zoos don't have
chimps because chimps well they just rip
each other to shreds oh yeah bro shrimps
are the most dangerous
bonobos they end up they end up having
sex they're like they're they're
matriarchal societies and the females
will take on a bunch of different so
they're they're basically the lover
eight it's not that they don't fight but
chimps bro they attack the face and the
genitals they'll they'll rip [ __ ] up
they're stronger than a human correct
right what even a small one marty do you
have the ability to bring up bring up
hairless chimpanzee oh that rocked out
one yeah
i saw a picture that's a champ that lost
its hair due to an allergy but look at
that oh bring that [ __ ] up [ __ ] no no
now enjoy that enjoy that [ __ ] that's
like a rock statue that's a real that's
a real [ __ ] that that thing will pull
your head off he's got old man strange
look at that [ __ ] right there
oh hell no gollum on steroids yes it was
like lord of the rings [ __ ] yeah bro
look at those hands even the small ones
rip your arm off bro are you kidding me
bill to tear you up i'm so glad we live
in civilization i don't live in the
jungle man well we're not equipped for
it no [ __ ] no we're not our teeth are
flat i'm good yeah
it's no joke so remember we started
talking about [ __ ] chips love it i
know i love it i always bring it back to
something weird um
so back to what i was i was going to
bring it up and you brought it up you're
not you're saying you just don't like
set life how was what was your first
movie that you ever got because i always
ask everybody that comes what was the
day you came
well not even i think my biggest first
big movie was old school
yeah yeah
i played the waiter love it's a
[ __ ] i'm the guy that's a great
movie i just watched the other day
does it still hold this it's so [ __ ]
funny still yeah still it's still funny
the that dude with his dick getting all
of it's funny is funny
i mean they're just amazing um so my
question was like i said i ask everybody
you've been doing this for a while
what was the day can you remember the
exact time where you walked in to your
house or apartment put your stuff down
went to the bathroom went holy [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] doing it because you know
there's that one sparkle you go
[ __ ] yeah you look yourself in the
mirror
that didn't happen until i was 48.
that's fine what's wrong with that
no i'm saying it's just funny yeah it
took forever but you know that there's
that moment you can remember like oh i
[ __ ] remember well i i came to l.a
and i wrote down the things i wanted to
accomplish and when i was like 48 50 or
something i i wrote i drew a line
through all of them
you know what i'm saying so the best
feeling yeah i kind of i kind of had one
on my own tv show and i wanted a big
huge podcast and i wanted to be a
national headliner
stand up and i and i kind of just drew
that but what's funny about all that is
that
you
you have to continue to inspire yourself
and find reasons
to challenge yourself yeah because
i don't know man i mean i didn't make as
much money as a lot of my friends
because i just was never i've never been
motivated by money and that's a problem
it really is it isn't it isn't though i
guess dude i stoke with you i make money
but i just i wish sometimes something
the problem with money for me is if you
gave me 30 million dollars
i
i might
give it all away or spend it on dumb i i
don't know i've never been comfortable
with with that
thing i don't know why i have a weird
relationship completely with it yeah so
i have it just get [ __ ] rid of it it
saves
your instrument it makes me not
motivated to go work that's me too
like i said i feel like it's in that
sense it's evil right like i feel like
if it does that to me if when i think
about money i think of a
a really amazing house with a view
and good wine and somehow
a comfy couch those are not good images
i think of
you're fine
do you want to know my exact id what did
i say
have air conditioning in your house your
big ass living room and have welch's
grape juice i made it i know that's
literally what the [ __ ] is yours is
alcoholic juice but that's like that's
what
that's what kids do that's like when
you're saying that when i was a kid
though i know you're all like comfy and
you're all like
well let's just have another day we
watch movies all day like sunday yeah
but that's that ultimately isn't going
to turns nothing into nothing right
my back hurts right it does sitting it
doesn't lead to fulfillment it leads to
comfort and comfort might be the wolf at
the door like comfortable truly is
comfort depression i [ __ ] hate
everything oh can i get it back well you
said to me the first thing you said to
me is you have like we were in your
warehouse and you're like i got all this
equipment to work out
you don't like it but you want to start
doing pull-ups you have to
yeah because somehow all of us the i
what i think is interesting is and i
don't think it's necessarily your
upbringing i i think there's an instinct
toward
self-restriction of some kind i believe
that when we indulge our sensations sex
drugs
food you know
what's that weed sleep all that
i feel like
what happens to us
is we we instinctively
somehow know it's what we want but not
what we need
that's a great [ __ ] way to put it do
you understand
the distance 100 yeah i want it but i
don't need it in fact i want it and i
shouldn't because i this is not what i
need as a human being something about my
soul or whatever this inner you know
one's bad there's inner [ __ ] yeah man
that's the same thing when you lie like
i'm a huge believer in living honestly i
mean really honestly like
like um so so what i mean by that is and
i haven't always done it at all
especially when it comes to
relationships and all that stuff but
or even in in it's not just that just in
the choices i made as an actor or you
know
but you get older and you start to
realize that the only thing the quitting
it closest to if you believe in god or
whatever it might be the way to get
closest to those kinds of things might
be radical honesty with yourself man
like if you really listen
to yourself really listen to what it is
you should do you know see you know you
if you if you stop the music for a
second none of us want to sit yeah if
you make yourself hesitate like and
nobody likes this [ __ ] man because it
comes with responsibility you stop the
music and sit
and listen you know man
you know the truth you know you
shouldn't eat that pie or you know you
shouldn't you know be drinking all that
booze you know you shouldn't be you know
having sex with 10 girls whatever it
might be that is your thing
we just know it's why we keep our vices
secret
it's why we always go yeah no i'm
quitting i know i don't do you know yeah
you do yeah you [ __ ] do we all do and
i just think that's interesting i don't
know where that goes but i do think that
we all have
like a nostalgia or sort of a um
a need to a need a sort of a a pesky
kind of it's like this it's like god if
let's just say god if you believe in god
forget god but it's like i know what it
is it's not god
it's like your best self is always in
the corner of your eye clearing his
throat every time you [ __ ] have a
great way of putting that that's a yo
you're on some prolific [ __ ] tonight you
understand because every time i'm like
yeah i'm [ __ ] fat buff me is over
there like do some push-ups [ __ ] right
yeah yeah yeah
right like a hundred percent thomas
thomas i'm over here the truth does that
with a fedora and a cigar going are you
doing that
and a cigar you're flipping a [ __ ]
nickel are you still in that
relationship oh cool are you still doing
this [ __ ] with the dessert oh cool yay
you still smoking weed every day and not
writing that script you're supposed to
i'll be over here with my sick you still
yeah you're doing all right you're still
in that job that that sucks your soul
but you're doing it for money yeah keep
doing that yeah i'll be over here with
my sister it's crazy because there is
that guy in my head of course i'm a
[ __ ] perfectionist i [ __ ] hate it
because i can't sleep so i'll be up all
night thinking of every single thing i
need to fix
and that's been about 25 years of my
life yeah could it even go away is the
question it will never go but so what
happens when you fix it
i my goals are so much bigger by that
time that that was like oh so what are
your
goals specifically uh to have a cult
classic movie really yeah since i was
about
seven so what what does your life look
like after that
we talked about this recently um
once i accomplish like my list
my thing is to go
cool you have that spark let me see if i
can help you mold your [ __ ] and get your
list crossed off
that's it like find the next person
that's doing that while i'm working on
my [ __ ] that's major over here hey let
me help you because you're genuine and
you're cool and i [ __ ] with you and
my goal is to help other people
accomplish the [ __ ] that they could have
come that they want to but they maybe
they can't like i was like i said i've
been working for free for a night in
[ __ ] years
but if someone saw it was like here's
two million dollars let's make some
stuff like [ __ ] yeah i'd be ten years
advanced yeah but i don't mind working
18 hours i [ __ ] that's my whole life
well it's fun it's fun like a lot of
times what you do like i don't consider
it like you want to bore me take me on
vacation
i'm talking about the best vacation
i went on one vacation my life like what
what what are we doing here
no it's it's
your work mind i'm a worker that's
that's what it is i did i was building
something yeah it's tough i'm always i'm
having to try to mature out of that you
know we went to hawaii for my uh vetting
wedding vowel renewals like a month ago
i had to really super deliberately be
like
be here it's hard enjoy yours turn your
phone off and leave it in the [ __ ]
room i'm [ __ ] wrong with me or no
it's not because you could work right
here i'm just trying to well they say
that men want to be significant like men
what's really important to men is to be
important women is a different
consideration sorry to everybody who's
gender police but like i'm saying
broadly
women tend to have a different
consideration from what i've
what i can what i can see
men i i don't want to speak for women
but men from what i've seen
being important and significant making a
mark that's important to them it is men
i would i would trade the mark to buy my
whole family houses that's like my
righteousness the mark is usually what
it's what puts me in the business
exactly
right exactly provider protector that's
the whole point it's deep that runs deep
enough provider protector that [ __ ]
there's an alarm going off at all times
until that's like solved in my mind it's
been oh for sure and how i have four
[ __ ] jobs yeah they're not always
done
i told you i want to do this i want to
do this
this first time i've talked about it but
i want to do this podcast i have this
idea for my patreon and i want to do a
thing called colin callum where people
call in where i take where i actually
take calls
from young people do it and it's
probably going to be a lot of young men
but but i hope women you know but but
for the most part
it's i wanna i i'm older and i've made
way more mistakes
and i just have better pattern
recognition and i and i think at this
age i'm able to give good advice and i
wanna i wanna do a podcast where i
literally i don't know if i'll ever make
any money it doesn't matter but i just
want to sit and i want to have a phone
and a chair and i want to take calls and
i want to talk to people
and i want to let everybody who wants to
just call me and have a and i'll do it
anonymously so they can ask me anything
because if you do it with facetime then
people can yeah
i want to do it like i just want to do
it anonymously you can call me and i'll
talk to you and i want to hear your
voice and i want to hear
i want to hear what your concerns are
and i want to see if i can help i'm
really interested to see what that's
going to look like and and the
motivation behind that is nothing other
than sasso gave me this idea by the way
oh really yes sasso told me do this and
i was like i should because i it's what
i love to do when i when i come off
stage i always have young people kind of
ask me questions you know then they
should yeah i would ask me questions if
i was my hundred percent right like if i
was when you and rogan came out that i
was hanging out with felons that
inspired me to be able to let go of my
friends and
because i'm like oh i resonate with
these people you saw older dudes who
were positive funny successful i'm like
oh this is who i am there you go i'm not
where i was born into these people
and that's what i want to do like i i do
think i have something to say and share
if you can make one person change yeah
well it has a ripple effect to it you
know yeah that person is going to make
their friend like damn this fool's doing
good well yeah let me try it it really
does
positivity man i met so many people in
person like hey i started doing all this
because you're [ __ ] this video
because you're talking about this
business this oh good [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's changed a lot podcasts have changed
lives dude just like this like just this
like like you and i wouldn't be just
talking like this for this long having a
real conversation without podcasts
i [ __ ] like he he really like i said
before podcasts i only saw two podcasts
in my life yours and obviously i've seen
rogan because
it's on the internet it's [ __ ] social
media i've seen like oh let me check it
out oh ufc people really know [ __ ]
and then he showed me everything and i
fell in love with it i can
you can make a friend from a podcast
person in one show yeah one episode
something but i [ __ ] love you well
people always say it to me they always
go i feel like i know you they do that
but they do you if you've just been
listening to fighter and a kid for seven
years you know me like i don't know
stuff that you don't remember and go i
never
oh [ __ ] i did do that oh dude what's
also humbling though is you'll see a
tape of yourself when you were in your
20s and you're like i haven't changed at
all
i mean in a lot of ways i'm i'm the same
guy
repeating the same things you know or or
just i have i i hold the same values i
it's good though i don't think so that's
the best
if you change like oh [ __ ] look at me
now well you get older
i think when you get older you're
supposed to be better at not chasing
sensation
sensations meaning like
like just the the carnal pleasures and
the appetites right
like you know it there's something
there's something really cool about
getting command of that you're in it
right now you're in the process of
trying to do that okay i can see it and
and like what happens is you get to a
point hopefully and this is what i'm
interested in i think this is where i'm
at where i have
command almost completely of all my
urges all my sort of
you know i hope yeah that's just the
idea it's not just the id but but i like
even like i love wine i don't even drink
it you know just certain things because
i enjoy the process of self-restriction
i enjoy the process of like you know
kind of feeling my ribs and kind of
i don't know man i feel like when you
hit 35 you're like okay this is who i am
like i know who i am like you're saying
like wine is my thing coffee's my thing
it is my thing i like coffee i'll never
give that [ __ ] out i wish i loved it man
i [ __ ] despised this [ __ ] but there's
definitely something to be said for like
i'm intentionally going to not indulge
in that oh for sure i'll set some
milestone deep fire
pictures and then i'll like circle back
to it yeah i have this joke where when
you're young you feel too deeply and
it's a liability right yes i mean it's
new to you so like you know my joke is
like you're like you're like what the
[ __ ] is this feeling and then you say
dumb things like let's move in together
or who needs money when we have each
other you know right when you get older
and something feels good you're like
what what who's paying for this i'm not
paying for this [ __ ]
there's like there's this is free
[ __ ] what's the catch
you know and we're right like like this
shouldn't feel this good i think i've
been thinking about this since i was a
kid well that's good then yeah i'm i'm
i'm the i'm the old man every time ever
when i was a kid like you know you're
gonna get [ __ ] hurt right
you ride the go-kart you grew up i'm
[ __ ] good because if i break my arm
my mom's not gonna want to pay for it
she's gonna beat the [ __ ] out of me for
having to go to the hospital yeah i know
it like i was funny you said that i
wonder if a lot of successful people i
know are actually inherently cautious i
think rogan's overly i don't do cocaine
anymore because of drugs because chris
farley yeah man one of my favorite
people ever when he died when i was a
kid i was [ __ ] heartbroken yep and he
just didn't do drugs and took that you
know what let me stop doing drugs i'm
overweight
i was with phil hartman when he died oh
we came back bro what a [ __ ]
legendary name you just brought up right
yeah i remember saying to him i was like
me and rogan i was playing rogan's
brother on news radio and i said to phil
hartman i've known each other that long
i've known rogan since i was 28. oh wow
27.
and uh
[ __ ] almost half your life damn near
right like that is correct sir damn that
is correct almost half my life it's so
weird
we used to hang out and we were yeah 27.
wow
so weird so you're with phil hartman
when that happened that's well we were
doing news radio and uh
i think i and i i think i remember
saying i said are you okay and he said i
said you okay and he said yeah i'm okay
yeah something like that i think he died
in fact i i hope i'm right about that
look up when can you look up when he
died
i'll tell you i think i should have i
think it's 1997. it's 97. it is it has
to be 97. so we were down
i was in new york and yeah there you go
yeah that was it and i was with we were
doing that episode
and uh
uh i remember i remember that and i it's
i and i i'm going to tell this story and
i and i hope i'm i didn't dream this
this is how long ago it is right i
always get nervous that i'm telling a
story that's not true because you don't
remember yeah but you don't but i
remember i at talking about chris farley
to hartman and he said it's a sad end
like that that ending that story doesn't
have a good ending foreshadowing and
then yeah and then and then he died and
then phil hartman how long ago was that
how long after that was that time i'm
sorry phil hartman died i think the next
year or two right yeah man it was it was
within two years yeah i were waking up
it was the front of the house there was
cops i was on tv and i was like seven or
eight just thinking are you [ __ ]
kidding me duffman i called rogue and
then that's five months after yeah see
it was right out i just remember
thinking god i worked with him troy
mcclure sorry not death man it's so
weird yeah [ __ ] troy mcclure dude
i i just remember i mean i used to watch
all that [ __ ] cone heads i used to watch
jingle all the way and
ev everything everything with with
i don't know if you could tell but i
grew up on movies my mom and my dad
weren't very good parents yeah so i just
watched it yeah but good for you
[ __ ] love it do you game are you a
gamer not at all i'm not here i got no
time my son's into that i wish i did man
it's fun to see the games now we're
[ __ ] amazing dude i was watching my
son plays games with his with his 10
year old friend and i'm like what the
[ __ ] dude i could never resist this [ __ ]
no wonder kids don't want you didn't
want to deal with me he's like dad i
don't want to talk to you right now i
haven't seen you in four days he's like
i'm sniped 75 people this morning
with you right he's like get out of here
and i'm like dude
i miss you but you know i've lost my
kids to the internet my daughter my
daughter has an anime addiction oh no
[ __ ] oh that's never going away anime's
for life i know 40 year old men that are
just [ __ ]
goku they are [ __ ] dragon ball weird
i think it's cool i've never watched it
i couldn't get into it well i like real
life like i don't know i mean some
people i was watching seinfeld when i
was four or five cent till today i just
been that kid yeah i [ __ ] hate you at
all i've only read three books in my
whole life what were the books death
watch which is a good ass [ __ ]
book rumble fish and full-time podcaster
there you go i gotta be honest guys uh
one of the other ones was a book report
is rumblefish a bukowski book you're
gonna have to tell me i don't know oh
okay i just remember rumblefish i'm like
yo this is kind of like you know uh
this is kind of like it's book it's not
no it's it's like uh
how am i spacing roblo
come on tom cruise patrick swayze
outsiders yes it's like an outsider
there's a movie too yeah
yeah i read rumblefish when i got kicked
out and had to move to portland because
i didn't have weed away i'm gonna
[ __ ] read i read the whole book in
one night and went damn i feel smart
and then i went back selling drugs
there you go and it's just ended yeah
yeah i don't read i need to
i guess i have time but i fall asleep
you were part of the american lost
that's what i call most
most of the young people i see a lot of
times i'm like oh you don't read much
it's just that no you no it's just that
most most of us at one point and the
other are just lost
you know what i mean like you see people
that just like if you if you actually
like i was watching
my my girl loves to watch trashy tv
right
so
it's mine yeah like whether it's like
the sh i was watching reruns of the
shaw's at sunset or i don't know what
that is
or the
housewives of whatever or
or fuckboy island or you know any of
these dumb shows and what's so
interesting is that the it's it's um
like most people spend their time
watching that but also the people that
are doing that they're trying to be that
so what that means is just having shiny
[ __ ]
and and then
the
job is to keep that shiny [ __ ] and keep
that [ __ ] shiny
just so you are
seen it's it's a very strange hamster on
a wheel kind of like twilight zone the
second the reality tv came out and p and
uh social media like oh she's pretty
validated her so much or valid oh he's a
good looking dude the need for
validation right now is so [ __ ] high
and reality tv just sparks it oh yeah
how much did you spend oh we're gonna go
to the louis vuitton this beverly house
wives or whatever yeah and then there's
about 300 wives in that neighborhood
going well i need to go buy that too
it's like damn dude they're advertising
without advertising just being trashy
ass people i love it they were social
animals
we're social animals man for sure but
you know then again like i always when
you're when you grow up poor like i
always sympathize with people you grow
up with money oh you didn't but when you
do grow up poor i know people i'm close
to some people like you know like my my
dad and stuff when you grow up poor
um there's nothing
glamorous about that [ __ ] it's
humiliating
it's [ __ ] embarrassing it's
embarrassing bro
all the time dirty it's embarrassing
it's all those things
so when you when you get older and you
make money and you buy that watch
and you buy that nice car
you're treated differently
you get out of the the valets treat you
differently when you step out of a
ferrari
damn amg out there yep everything was i
stopped getting looked at by cops there
you go a hundred that was my biggest
thing that's what happened it was so
[ __ ] awful if a woman grew up poor
and she
she has a fendi bag she gets treated
differently it's weird so i've never
i've never um begrudged someone who came
up hard and poor
for
surrounding themselves with nice things
i think it's great yeah man it's it's a
it's a security blanket and being like i
said i'll just want some grape juice and
air conditioning because we didn't have
air conditioning we could drink grape
drink from the 99 cent store so i was
like damn well just grape juice that's
the rich kid [ __ ] damn you're gonna be
like isn't it funny it's [ __ ] but you
see what you're talking about right now
is like the other thing that's really
important is
like i think you you must hold on to
the
ability
to distinguish between the meaningful
difference
you know like
when you stop being able to taste the
difference between great drink and grape
juice when you stop being able to like
okay when you stop feeling that the the
change in temperature in a room like
there's something about um
i totally understand what you're saying
you know what i mean man yeah like like
just even like the the amount of time
somebody takes to prepare a good meal
versus just [ __ ] food
man you
you know that's important it is it's
also important to understand and learn
the difference between a good idea and a
bad idea or or kind of like my way of
that is true can you leave your idea
here with your friends walk out and go
this [ __ ] is stupid if you can
do that without that feeling it's
probably a good idea yeah cause your
friends are gonna be like
yo this is stupid you're gonna do this
this is [ __ ] dumb you mean this brand
that's already doing it if nobody does
that it's a good idea so when every time
i think of something like
would i make fun of me
no i'm good yeah that's a good judge
it's a good judge because when did you
start when did you know you wanted more
because you grew up really poor eight
right i bought simon birch the movie
simon burch the little guy yeah and then
he was like i'm gonna grow up and be
something i'm gonna change i'm gonna do
something significant go me [ __ ] too
and that was it do you see how important
story is it's it's it's stories are a
story and mythology it's a mythology
what you're talking about is you saw
what was possible even though it was
fake even though it was a movie i knew
it was fake stories are story story
whether it's in movies tv or on a book
is or even verbally men is like from
somebody's mouth
that it it's so crucial it's so crucial
because i learned how to behave in
defeat for example from movies
like i learned how to lose properly
everything i learned is movies yeah man
hundred percent because there's a moral
lesson in good movies good movies again
like the character gives up what what he
wants for what he needs
you understand like good movies okay you
know what i mean like i'll give you all
the money because i learned that i'm
selfish and i got to start thinking
about other people that would be the you
know theme of certain like midnight run
one of my favorite movies or whatever a
lot of movies like that well you you you
there's a moral lesson that the
character learns in the end and kind of
you kind of like go damn bro 100 i gotta
wait like whoa yeah
here's the point that's the whole point
of movies
i learned all my street [ __ ] from
goodfellas hey carrick go over there you
know inside oh don't walk down alleys
how about that [ __ ] and i just don't
listen to dudes and you have a bad
feeling [ __ ] walk away yeah i knew
that
from that movie my mom like where's my
mom
well what's funny about criminal
organizations is even then there's
discipline right there's like always
there's a code he's like why'd you buy
that there's a million bulls looking out
for you buy a cadillac twenty thousand
dollar mango he's stupid that guy's
stupid and i'm a six year old one
so robert was a good one
and like you know i'm going through all
these
things like so henry hill's a snitch he
should just went to jail
and at the end he's eating mac what
spaghetti into ketchup
the more my mom always said at the end
of movies what would you guys learn
what'd you think what did you uh
basketball diaries see
listen to your mom he's crying on the
ground and on drugs that's she'll listen
to his mom that's what she told me
scared the [ __ ] hey movie dude i was
like five
six how about dicaprio in that movie man
he was 17 years old crushed it damn
oh
is it marky mark in that one
uh yes he's the piece of [ __ ] on the
roof yes right yes yeah yeah yes he is
that one got me when i was a kid my mom
showed me all the kramer versus kramer
see don't get with the girl that you're
not gonna like
all right
got it that's why i learned all my
stuffs from movies and when mom wasn't
there i would like
what did i learn from this movie yeah
except like jurassic park and that [ __ ]
to learn yeah you know don't move don't
move when a dinosaur is in the room they
can see movement that's all i learned i
i learned things from every move
give me the five seminal movies the five
movies that kind of changed everything
for you
forrest gump truman show american beauty
good movies bro those are the ones
you're a thoughtful dude those are like
[ __ ] ones
and i saw it we saw american beauty and
like he was like it's the best movie
ever seen i was like unbelievable movie
and then
and then i get a call like three days
later
my it was maybe his cousin i don't know
for the story i can't believe my cousin
doesn't like american beauty i'm pissed
and i'm always like the kind of guy
who's like well how old is he he's 23.
and i was like he's young and he goes no
he's not he's [ __ ] stupid he's doing
stupid huh i was watching this show i
was like nine or ten going this is some
good [ __ ] because the first time i
ever saw
mortality being okay yeah i did like
kevin spacey like in one year i will be
dead here's the story and guys just like
it [ __ ] me up like bro i had a i know
an afghani guy
um who
said he's religious
and uh he said uh i'm gonna you know i
got you know maybe 10 20 years i said
what do you mean because the men in my
family don't live long world encoding to
garp i know and i was like i was like
yeah dude but you might you know you
might and he goes uh
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not afraid to
die
and i was like i found that so
liberating i was like like he was just
he was here to do some [ __ ] and he
didn't have a time to didn't there was
no he wasn't he was already living
ready to die yeah like like he was
already living correctly like he was
living in a way
where that it where if he dies tomorrow
it's okay how many people are doing that
i'm not how many people are living
like in a way where if you die tomorrow
like i got more i want to do but but you
should be living in a way where if you
die tomorrow you'll be like all right at
least i was on my way at least i was
reaching for my best self oh for sure
that is every day i felt like that when
i got life insurance this pool literally
said i grew up today
i just got [ __ ] up i got three kids
right yeah yeah
how old are your kids thirteen seven and
three i got thirteen
ten and ten yeah
twins
no thirteen and a ten-year-old third oh
they said two three one girl
and she's going on 25 it's
my buddy started the other day well
you're a full-grown woman now so that's
cool have you had to almost fight any
teenagers yet because not yet she's not
she's not married almost beat up a
12-year-old boy it's there's been all
kinds of things
is that right no barney almost tracked
down is your daughter
adorable or something and boys like her
well yeah i mean she looks just like me
so
yeah yeah no it's just it's a lot of
there's you know bullying there's just
regular dudes doing dude [ __ ] i would
hate to be a kid right now
without worse it's just better actually
isn't it i don't think so i mean but
they have anti-bullying remember think
about this it's all this acceptance or
no b13 and be able to go
all these other girls at my school are
half
naked this isn't [ __ ] good for me i'm
gonna go do math i'm gonna do [ __ ]
math yeah right even when we were like
no it wasn't normal for kids to be like
well then [ __ ] kill yourself you
piece of [ __ ] yeah the internet gave
people
a shield internet kids used to get
knocked the [ __ ] out when saying [ __ ]
like that and then it's like completely
different blocked
different account one little piece of
[ __ ] could just make everyone's day bad
social media is damn come on man
remember a rumor starting in high school
imagine someone going let them post that
rumor
when school's over [ __ ] school's all
right to move schools that's true dude i
think it's it's worse i think it's worse
now but school's easier you don't have
to study just do this [ __ ] during the
[ __ ] test that's what i would be
doing i was trying to cheat you're right
dude how do you how do you stop people
from googling the answer
you don't airpods and watches like how
do you patrol all that you gotta you
don't you can't that's why kids are
[ __ ] well learning has to be yeah
like there are some things i don't teach
people what to think i teach them how to
think
you know what i mean so learning how to
think and learning how to how to learn
how to unlearn and unlearn and relearn
that's really the same some adults can't
do that [ __ ] well that's what you need
in the 21st century how do you learn
unlearn and relearn i mean for real
because technology is moving at such a
clip
and everything's moving in such a clip
that you know entire industries are
going out of you know 100 so what do you
do now
that's the name of my whole business you
know every year i'm going to add on
something new that brings more value
that wasn't what i started with right
that i mean that's how you got to do it
no matter what energy i don't know how
it applies to every industry but i mean
what he's saying i know for me it was
[ __ ] exactly how it's gone do you
know what's crazy you know what [ __ ]
blew my mind today my friend came from
merced just to hang out and i haven't
really met his kid yet he's three he's a
little boy
i have a
shelf full of old school like 80s toys
and stuff i've just kept since i was a
kid and this little boy went over and
grabbed the rotary fake rotary phone i
went
he doesn't know what the [ __ ] it is
holy [ __ ] he's gonna have no idea what
the [ __ ] that is and he went like that
and go you're a smart ass kid
cause think about it yeah no [ __ ]
idea what a rotary phone is yeah i
haven't seen one of those in my
grandma's house a rotary phone how weird
i love them i love doing that that is
weird within our lifetime that
it's like
not if you don't know what it don't even
know what it is
and it [ __ ] blew my mind today fossil
it's very true dude artifact yeah it's
pretty wild and it makes me feel like
well you're not a young little boy
anymore [ __ ] yeah i know man i'm just
come into reality with it i just turned
31 so i'm like
you know my brain is like yeah yeah
because all i did was sell drugs from 16
to
i started doing videos
yeah yeah yeah i was just selling pounds
and [ __ ] and it's just california man
that's merced is drug capital yeah it's
nobody has a job but there's always
drugs like you made most of your money
on weed
i mean that's all i did i used to sell
pizza i used to have a delivery driver
job and i would sell sacks in my pizza
bag but pretending i was dropping pizza
it was the
it was the best cover i ever had besides
the meth head that lived under me sold
meth and i lived above so nobody thought
they were buying meth oh damn
he ran the apartments so he ain't
getting in trouble i mean i might get in
trouble that was the second best cover i
ever had this is why i think drugs
should be illegal because enforcement
there's a lot of money in enforcement
but how's that going how's that war on
trump [ __ ] about this every episode oh
no for real how's that war on drugs
since the pandemic i don't know if you
guys know but the black market drug
thing has
probably went up 500 at least why i have
because you ready everybody's sitting at
home
they just got a 1400 check not everybody
smokes an ounce a day so they buy one
ounce it lasts them for a month now they
got expendable weed
i have a couple friends that do black
market things
and these guys i've
probably made four times four or five
money the money from 19 to 20
just like that
i've seen it for the fake you know vape
carts and stuff the black market on that
is unbelievable really
talking like three four mil a month
damn it's awesome
really oh yeah wait three or four mil a
month off black markets there's
untaxable parts that they go out and
bootleg and they bootleg them so you get
a real one at the store and go hey how
much to make that fake packaging all
right cool and i'm gonna tell this guy i
got 30. okay but here's the problems
when you get paid in cash nobody takes
cash anymore yeah i know but they just
throw it into bitcoin they buy one piece
of art now they're an art dealer
damn or a giant glass or giant glass you
know some of those little
bongs or two three hundred thousand
fifty thousand
what do you mean some of these little
glass rigs you smoke out of yeah put in
the bumblebee i smoked out of that once
and it's 110 000. come on but it's glass
art it really is sure i know
it's functional it's it's this
it's your drug dealer you make wax dabs
how are you going to get buy a house i'm
going to buy that rig and when i sell
that rig i got 100 000 clean money now
i'm an art dealer bumble bee dab rig 100
000.
it's on it's this big though
they truly are that one on the fourth
one the fourth one
that right there and that's expensive
it's a hundred something thousand
godzilla's hilarious but every smoke
goes through every piece of glass
it's completely functional wow
that might be a knock off i got to be
honest but still
i mean wow think about it it is art it's
a
it's like that's how these fools wash
their arms that's how they wash your
money what's that that's how you wash
your money
that's so crazy start a little caesars
with a guy that's legal and then funnel
your money my friends 18 bought a baby
he bought a subway just so he could
funnel his money out did you just put
him on blast no [ __ ] no it's been
12 years
yeah i mean
the black market's pretty crazy how the
[ __ ] do we get in this topic because
we're talking about crime yeah okay
there we go talking about crime well
speaking of crime um
how the [ __ ]
sorry how did we get on that topic i my
brain just as soon as i started talking
about drugs and numbers my brain just
hey what's up guys i just want to take a
minute to talk about one of our sponsors
this is keeps so for the past couple
episodes you've been seeing keeps in the
ad reads mainly because we thought it's
something that our audience might
resonate with something that you might
see and go you know what i'm gonna
[ __ ] try it so let me tell you a
little bit about keeps this is a men's
hair loss men's rejuvenation hair
treatment out of all the [ __ ] you see on
tv hey take this pill to work take this
out of all the things you've ever seen
in your entire life there's only two
medicines two treatments approved by the
fda for hair loss and they offer both i
understand that i have hair now what
about in 10 years this is hair
thickening shampoo it's to prevent the
cause of hair loss let me drop a scary
ass fact of knowledge on you real quick
two out of three men in the world all
right the earth that we live on two out
of three men by the time they get 35
will have some form of hair loss and i'm
just gonna say i am not far off from
that age so i'm gonna take the steps i
ain't trying to lose this [ __ ] so if you
wanna check it out go to
www.keeps.com forward slash yola and
that gives you your first month for free
the whole first month is for free so
some people don't wanna go to the doctor
it's an embarrassing thing they don't
want to admit it so if you want to try
this out this is discreet this comes to
your door there's no doctor visit you
don't have to do any of that stuff go
sit in the waiting room fill out the
stuff it's a virtual consultation guys
there's no doctor's visit it's the
easiest thing you can do to take the
first step there is no other hair growth
company on the planet with more five
star reviews and that says enough so
guys once again go to
www.keeps.com forward slash yola and
that's your first month of treatment for
free thank you guys so much for watching
back to the
episode no i think you're saying that
you sold drugs until you were oh yes yes
um i just used to sell packs and
have jobs and go to school
that's all i ever did but nobody ever
thought because were you a good student
[ __ ] no i uh i used to be in all the
gifted classes yeah but i'm that kid
that's
i hate school yeah well you can't sit
and be told i can't well it's not that
i'd be sitting there doing my [ __ ] just
i'm [ __ ] bored
boring dude so [ __ ] boring my son
like he can't sit still i don't blame
him i couldn't either so i can't tell me
like you feel evil waking him up at the
ass crack of dawn yeah
food in his face shoving him out the
door all of it is like i hate it man i
wasn't a good student i wasn't either um
i was later on like
college i got better i didn't what'd you
study
i still haven't graduated sorry i
stopped i went to a two-year for five
years like one credit away though right
i'm one i'm one class it has to be
relevant it's just it was about this is
not relevant anymore the only thing you
go to college for is is
okay so go to college and get a
communications degree see how that does
for you see how that does for you
besides put you in depth
history major or whatever it is gender
studies whatever it is good luck good
luck specialized skill yeah i think it
should be trade schools yeah bro or you
know even computer like engineering i
guess like what they say is the first
year you learn like computer you know i
don't know what coding or like what you
learned is already obsolete by second
year that's [ __ ] stupid it says how
fast it's moving i don't know if that's
true but i've heard that probably is
true yeah it probably is but the trade
schools are good man i think they should
do it because i'm not going to learn
computers i need somebody else to learn
it so they can just do all the
industrial sciences i'm just i'm like
you see like 25 26 is the right age to
make that choice like i know who i am
now like i'm going to get myself into
youtube you can also educate yourself on
on youtube you can take classes
this guy yeah
did you see we talked about this last
episode did you know the guy the
the javelin did you watch the olympics
oh yeah do you remember the javelin
thrower from india i was a javelin
thrower and i were you really yes
oh [ __ ] i always wonder how do you get
into just throwing spikes i just could
throw far i don't know how or why did
you have that weird wind up and almost
fall [ __ ] i was like first of all i i
was a wrestler so wrestling
were you yeah wrestling was you'd be
sucking weight and it was winter and it
was the worst it sucked and then
track it'd be like spring and it was
just girls and i was like i'll throw the
javelin and do the pole vault back
you did yeah i did shopping just because
i was didn't want to run were you a
competitive weightlifter
no i used to do like
when i got kicked out of i got kicked
out when i was in high school i had to
move to oregon
and i was always freakishly strong i
played football and i started everything
so i'm sitting there just repping i'm
like all right what are those plaques
and there was plaques for the top
weights of the history of the school and
i came back two days later and i was on
every [ __ ] one of them at the top i
go bro i just maxing out holy [ __ ] good
and then and they're like you know what
let me start doing that and i started
just taking it serious i was eating
[ __ ] tuna and lettuce every day just
trying to get swole i had no weed and no
friends i just got kicked out i had no
car
i was working as a mover it's getting
thick i was just
a little beast and then i was like you
got a car and you have drugs and money
you're gonna get fat as [ __ ] i guarantee
you and that's exactly what happened
thick boy that's all that [ __ ]
happened
so that's why i got all this stuff again
because i'm like
why like why just get strong yeah i know
could you imagine a year i'm just so
what's up guys [ __ ] yeah just to do it
crazy strong just to do it i want to
bench 350s i just i want to get back why
not like i want to be strong again you
have the advantage of like
we grew up quick so we forget it but
like we're really just coming into
adulthood now we really yeah i told you
yeah that that and i always say
you can't be a fat guy and and and on tv
and it just doesn't work you're a
character you're now a character best
friend you cannot you cannot market a
fat person
funny you can
yeah but i'm not trying to play the
funny fat guy forever and like i never
talk so you want to do a movie you want
to be an actor in a movie
so i've when i was selling weed and [ __ ]
i'm like you know what i'm going to stop
i'm going to move to la i was 20. i'm
going to just try it i'm going to go try
it because i just thought it'd be fun
you know what being extra just to laugh
my goal was
i'm gonna smoke a joint on tv one day
just to laugh and then my friend was on
key and pill
and he's sitting there smoking a [ __ ]
joint on tv and i just
[ __ ] like no way this is the coolest
thing i ever saw
so i forgot about that started dating
rosie and a year later i started doing
all this
so i gave up on it and it ended up
happening
who are your favorite actors
my favorite actors um i'm gonna say
dustin hoffman
you're going old school bro he's great
you ever seen a little big man i've seen
it all oh [ __ ] lovely so surprised
you're talking about 1971 yeah 72.
[ __ ] not playing around no no i
knew you're a big man little big man is
one of my favorite movies dude that's an
amazing movie it's so good that's the
one reason i'm not scared to die god
because i even said when i was a kid
when i get old and i go on top of a
mountain today today's a good day to die
i'm not going to be scared i think crazy
horse was the guy who actually said that
the no no no i'm saying not in the movie
i mean oh you told me in real life yeah
because i think crazy horse was the guy
that wrote backwards in that movie they
called him crazy yeah but he washes with
sand that dries with water yeah that's
where it came from
he was a bad [ __ ] i just as a
kid that that really
today is a good day to die that just got
me he's sitting there i'm not dead
let's go back and like it was just so
like what a good [ __ ] ending yeah man
i love that in your routine at one point
no that line it's a good day to die i
probably
probably cause i always say being a guy
is exhausting because you got to pretend
that today is a good day to die and you
have all the answers yeah yeah [ __ ] that
right i'll tell you do you fight for i
don't know how to solve this if you can
hire somebody yeah police you just can't
be vulnerable you're not allowed to cry
you know like
you can't talk about your feelings
really is a guy i think that's
i mean that's not as much anymore maybe
not my generation [ __ ] for generations
it's different you have to hit your hand
yeah bro i'm good i was never in my
generation i would never look at my
friend and go what's going on
here i don't know
but yo you all right you look sad as
[ __ ] yeah that's what i would say we try
to fix the problem right always
your generation the parents had it right
we're gonna listen it's the sun's going
down you kids shut the [ __ ] up nobody
talk unless we talk to you we're smoking
cigarettes we're drinking you guys go
upstairs that sounds [ __ ] horrible
we're all hanging out but i'm saying it
was about the parents
the kids were like tenants marty's a dad
now it's about the [ __ ] kids
it is kind of true marty because now
kids are indulged like think about
psychology and make sure you're not
stifling their creativity not stifling
their personal serenity and make sure
that they they can express themselves
and maybe that's all good i don't know
i've never heard anybody say that in
person i think it's the people you put
you surround yourself with because i
heard somebody talk like that have you
ever been a cafe gratitude
yeah i have i almost left it's annoying
i almost [ __ ] left i had the two i
bought soup there and the two sweet gals
but they were like what are your goals
and i was like i'm old i'm living my
goals they were like you are oh that's
so profound i was like i gotta get move
my soup i gotta get in the morning
yeah that lady wouldn't give me my food
unless i told her what i was grateful
for that day
three times she said i go just just give
me dude a lot of that [ __ ] i like
practicing gratitude i get it i i like
it but a lot of this stuff is
procrastinating it's supposed to be
subtle it's not supposed to be something
it's also procrastination like grandma's
boy you know what's up i was just
hanging out with uh nick uh what's his
name the director of that movie uh nick
starts with a g oh gooseman nick guzman
yeah thank you yeah cause doc peter i
don't know where he was with him last
night he's super i saw him today
actually super cool yeah he's good
people really cool but yeah everybody
talks like uh david spade and grandma's
boy shiloh yeah they're all very like
they talk quiet i just
i think it's just the a or maybe how you
grew up because it's more how you grew
up
the thing about it is that one of the
advantages of growing a poor or growing
up hardware is that there's no time for
anything but what works
your time
bro i don't have time to indulge in your
um in in sort of what's
i don't know what feels right
or what feels you know
that's not a luxury
you know you're not even allowed like a
lot of families like hey shut the [ __ ]
up and do your homework a 100 you know
or or i'll or i'll whip you with me i
break your [ __ ] legs yeah that's the
one i used to get you get that [ __ ] yeah
you know
the people they will you know you should
never do that or not i i got you i got
you but
but the world up until now was built on
that on people like that yeah yeah they
have issues but at the same time i feel
like it's part of your job as a dad that
your kids know that their world can come
crumbling down life's a kick in the nuts
yeah look at the end of the day there's
that book of the subtle art of not
giving a [ __ ] and he has a real book
yeah it's a great amazing it's actually
a great book it's called the settler not
giving a [ __ ] and he said
you got to ask yourself what you're
willing to struggle for because
everything is a struggle if anybody is
telling you this is why my problem with
self-help books if anybody's talking to
you about a [ __ ] shortcut or three
easy steps run the other way you don't
learn anything that way you don't man it
takes you got to do [ __ ] wrong for a
long time
to be right but stand up is that way you
want to be good to stand up suck up a
lot yeah that's always say i'm gonna if
i want to do it i'm gonna have to go
suck dick at it for a year yeah crickets
yeah
people wanted to fight me like
because a couple years ago i told him
like stand up would be so well you might
be able to do it because you you
communicate you've been communicating a
long time just write what you think is
funny write everything oh i have a water
boy notebook i've been writing for like
four or five years probably but like i
said i'm a perfectionist
let's go nervous is full come on man
forget your skit first of all that that
perfection stuff is an excuse so kick
that the [ __ ] out the back window oh no
i meant like what are you gonna
understand it's just
i don't know we talked about it last
year then
just get up and do a stand all right
tell a story
tell a story and add jokes in it that's
all you got to do that's my whole life
yeah bro exactly what it is so the
stand-up is this just start with a story
and then just so you don't don't you're
not there to stand up get up and just go
no i need to get it i've never said it
out loud i know that's not true either
you're telling me stuff that's not true
you have good pacing okay well thank you
these are all excuses
for me like being not prepared is scary
like not everybody says
it's all scary but you can do it tell a
story and within the story just just
have jokes that's mine i promise bro
yeah i have five minutes i've done we
did our stupid seinfeld [ __ ] yeah i have
five minutes
planning on kind of following the
fighter in the kid model like if i'll
take you back a few years where like you
had the first show at the bray improv
and then you guys did a tear across the
country and then like you know yeah i
was just doing live i would put brendan
i would pretend to be late so he had to
go out alone oh that's [ __ ] genius
and he'd have to go out alone yeah and
be like calallen's late yeah and i would
call him and say i'm in traffic i'll be
there and he goes god damn it because i
was always late and so he would have to
do that
so he'd have to like be up there just
telling a story yeah and then um
one day i said uh all right you're gonna
go out there and you're gonna do 10
minutes he goes i don't know how to do
stand up and i go you've been doing
santa baba you've been doing santa this
whole time get out there and tell a
[ __ ] it was 2100 people
good in seattle go tell a story and he
was like oh okay and he did yeah
the scary thing for me is not the people
it's not [ __ ] up it's
not being prepared like i haven't said
it out loud
in my room just did the whole little bit
i've never done that once i do it three
times i'm fine like into that commercial
with no practice i was [ __ ] fine got
it all on one too you got to watch our
commercials we did he's amazing oh that
and i'm talking about the the production
one i was like holy [ __ ] it's three
minutes i feel like you're a good actor
and i feel like you'd be a good stand-up
i i'm thank you i'm trying but just do i
need to do but
what's the first show you ever did
what's the first stand-up thing you ever
[ __ ] dude
it was stand-up it was stand-up new york
i was so nervous i thought i almost ran
away have you ever been in a real fight
where you're like and the guy's gonna
kick your ass and you can't feel your
legs i was more afraid than that i was
like i don't know if i can do this and i
just did it
and i blanked halfway through but i was
pretty funny because i was so ready you
know but um
but it i don't care if you're afraid it
doesn't matter and it doesn't matter if
it's good or bad you just have to do it
you know you have to right for sure 100
yeah you got to do it yeah let's go
that's part of the plan that's the house
part of the plan you'll be great dude i
want to you know honestly i want to try
because i've been communicating for a
long time just tell stories tell stories
and add funny in them i could help you
in 10 seconds yeah i got i got one story
that i wrote into like an eight-minute
thing but it's if it makes me go you're
[ __ ] stupid then it's funny to me but
i like it yeah then i like like you know
you're a [ __ ] idiot
then it makes me laugh
dude i have a street fight in french why
do i do that because i want it just so
you have a street fight in french yes i
have a bit where i i literally speak
french through the whole bit that was
the show i was at they don't even know
what the right are you talking about
rhinos too yes i was talking about the
same show
again like who talks about running some
of it was dramatic and i don't care
that's what makes it funny right and you
don't expect it so i was just like i
want to do that and that's not supposed
to work but i was in the shower and i
was like i want to talk about fighting
in french and so i did and it works
shower and about to fall asleep is where
i get all my ideas right right that
happens i think because your brain shuts
off or something my brain never i i
everything i write i'm like sorry go to
sleep i'm just [ __ ] typing some [ __ ]
francis ford coppola said that he said
screenplays are written while standing
in line on the hoods of cars
you get your best ideas when you're when
i'm not doing anything yeah when you
give up on the idea when you're like
[ __ ] i can't think oh hey wait a minute
you know it's that those sparks
yeah yeah you got to follow the sparks
this is idea you know
that you you ha all of us have sparks of
genius but most of us say nah not me i'm
not a genius i'm not gonna follow that
and then what happens is you see it
somebody else does it somebody else does
it and you see it in its in its full
majesty
and it comes back at you and you're like
damn that's my motivation that was me
that's my motive you said which
motivates you seeing something going oh
good [ __ ] job i gotta do something
better yeah not like competition more of
you just made me want to get up yeah
that's what keeps me ralph walter
emerson i think um he was the one who he
wrote
an essay called self-reliance and it's
about that
it's about yeah dude it's like a little
competition game in my head yeah bro
because because if you you if you don't
listen to that that's again it goes back
to just stay quiet man can you stay
quiet and can you listen
because you know you know that voice is
there and a lot of times i think most
people are drinking and and drugging
and even playing super loud music in
their car
to make sure
they don't that that voice doesn't get
too loud because that comes with
responsibility
because that voices that voice that
again your best self is clearing his
throat over there going hey bro over
here man you're hanging with the
vampires how much of that is diagnosed
as like anxiety disorder all of it
martin you're right all of it
it's a great question i think most of it
is because you're not telling the truth
so it it manifests itself as anxiety a
hundred percent
i love i love that feeling though
it's like a little it's like a little
guide
whenever i know i'm [ __ ] up yeah but
you're successful that's why you're
doing all that's why you work hard
that's why you have all this stuff going
on right
yeah i mean no one else is going to do
it i know yeah people people are drawn
to that they see it and they're like
wait but don't you feel like if i sat
down for two i did it the other day on
saturday i sat down didn't do any work
for one [ __ ] hour and i paid
attention to something
i haven't done that in like 10 years
beautiful it's so [ __ ] fun dude
that's beautiful and nobody was with me
rosie was at her boxing class i was
just i'm gonna smoke this bowl and just
sit that that's that thing called flow
right like flow so so you know the zone
when you're in the zone but one of the
things i love about nietzsche and i love
about schopenhauer the the the great
philosophers
is that they talked about um
the idea that when you when you produce
or even experience great art
you know music
a movie that makes you laugh and cry
an amazing painting
an incredible book a story then that you
get lost in
the value is that you forget you're
human for a minute what i mean is you
forget you are a biological creature
with biological needs
when you're moved by a song in your car
and you start to cry or whatever it is
or or you see a movie and you're like
[ __ ] this is the best movie ever
or or or whatever are you reading a book
and you're just engulfed in it you know
like this is the best story
you don't have to go to the bathroom
have sex you don't have to do any of
that [ __ ] it's a great way to i know
exactly yeah so you all of a sudden
you're in this arrested development
you're in this or well not even that you
might be in high relief you might be you
might be hot you might be um
you might be
touching
your highest self you might kind of that
that's where you feel the purest where
you're like dude
like you feel like a good person you
know what i mean i was listening to
andra day and she was singing rise up
you know that song and i was listening i
know a little bit about her story not a
lot but her mother used to drive her i
think from san diego all the way to l.a
or vice versa just to get take voice
lessons they didn't have any money i
think they live in that one bedroom a
mother and a daughter
bro
when she sings
birds fall from the sky
that woman can sing man and they're
singing and they're sanging you know she
can
i i was listening at [ __ ] and i was like
i if if if god doesn't exist then then
like if you don't believe in god when
you listen to her sing that song and you
watch what it took to get there i don't
know man like that you forget first
understand what you're saying yeah you
forget when you get stuck you feel and
you feel pure you feel like a good like
the best person you are you feel
you like when i listen to a song like
that i mean i want everyone everywhere
to be okay
i don't know no i know what you're
saying yeah i know zach was saying
there's only been i'm getting something
like i'm getting very sentimental in my
old age here that's good though man
[ __ ] don't open that part of
their brain often do you want another
one of those sipping tequilas no i'm
afraid not okay thank you very much i
don't think i've ever seen anybody
sipping my tequila that's a gentleman
yeah yes i'm an aristocrat i am now very
much wants to take everyone's been drunk
[Music]
drunk english so you know he's drunk he
started slipping into accident different
accidents suddenly this is my this is
who i am i'm from england the american
accent so i could imagine this guy's a
kid could you imagine
different countries pretending to be
so no i'm from did you ever just put a
whole character out
that's all you did yesterday good of
course what an opportunity to go all
right let's see how [ __ ] good i can
do this yeah yeah no i have no parents i
can't
i am orphan
how did you get you're on the base
i for me i am hungry so i am following
you know
just i can smell the food so if i could
have some food so was that your choice
to do that voice in the hangover or do
they go hey can you was your choice yes
they were like yeah good my character
did not have when it was written did not
have an accent really no i was with ken
jong and
and bradley and
and you know
zach and all those guys and and i said
that todd phillips director i said if he
owns a wedding chapel in vegas he should
be from armenia
or from lebanon or from somewhere like
this he should talk this way you know
because i can i have i can make good
wedding for you i can make good best
price a very good price for you for your
best deal for your best practices
those people whether you're armenian
syrian
lebanese they're so entrepreneurial you
can put them you can put those most
complaints on the planet and they will
make money they will find a way
to to get you what you need they start a
business they're so tight their families
are tight as [ __ ] i asked the question
lebanese people syrians people don't
know about syrians same thing with
syrians and armenians they're all my
neighbors armenian oh and i asked the
guy recently oh i have her own business
why do i feel like all our meetings just
made him money i asked him i asked him
like why why do i see every armenian
with a g wagon and a gt and he goes you
know what he told me
he's all so this is this is what it's
like i came here with no money armenians
like nice clothes cologne
mercedes and don't like to buy houses
he's like we don't like we don't care
about property we want to leave when we
want so we rent yeah he goes we start a
business get the nicest car dress how we
want and rent the [ __ ] and they're tight
communities they keep their money
together because like oh yeah my cousin
he's coming over here i'm going to give
him a store and he's going to come up
that's where it should be support the
family the way it should be yeah there's
i love it i want a little caesars for my
summer versions are the same way dude
it's persians whether they're jews or
shia or whatever they stick together
it's the best thing you could do and
they make money man they just figure out
on the block you ever see one person
with a store they on the block oh yeah
dude oh merced it's always middle
easterns all the liquor store you own
the whole [ __ ] block the laundromat
the little series everything that's
right because why [ __ ] not i know
because once you think about it go to a
small town buy a block it's 500 000 yeah
but up 500 000 house here i'm [ __ ]
with the bums and living dead but that
culture like that ability to think long
term physicality education all that [ __ ]
man it's great as soon as i got a little
older i realized a five-year plan is
nothing five years will be here tomorrow
so now it's more of all right what can i
get done in five years ethnic the ethnic
chinese are that way chinese are like
their kids you'll practice four [ __ ]
hours a day
at the cello or at the piano
and then you'll play tennis and oh by
the way you'll get straight a's and
that's the way it is dude and i'll work
18 hours and sleep on the floor of my
little bodega if i have to but that's
the way it is so uh tough people man
i'll [ __ ] sleep in this [ __ ] if i
need to yeah yeah but just because
growing up [ __ ] poor well every one
in my family's hard ass worker my
they're all truck drivers every one of
them yeah and my grandma just stopped
truck driving everyone just stopped
driving my dad still i talked to my dad
last night he's still in the seasons i'm
going to pacheco pass stay number 16. oh
he's nons my dad is like he makes me
work hard because seeing him like oh
you're older than me i need to work
harder than that because doing the
moving company i see him lift something
but well i'm stronger than my dad
that's one thing i always like [ __ ] yeah
i'm stronger than what you do
my dad's a big [ __ ] but when he sees me
lift the fridge and he go you can't do
that i used to be a little competition
like what can i do better
my dad just turned 52
yeah yeah young men are strong like
that's my nephew is 19. that mother that
kid is strong way stronger than me yeah
but older man strength is real i don't
want to fight my dad
yeah
but i definitely bench more than him but
he might take my [ __ ] head off if we
if we got in a fight
he's meaner
my dad's the nicest guy ever but i think
he's got that strength of like a bit of
dude's face off yeah my dad's a wild
[ __ ]
he bit some dude's [ __ ] face off once
try to rob him yeah my dad's crazy but
he's a truck driver and he
he's been a truck yesterday he's 14 15.
because my grandma and them in the 70s
you can [ __ ] drive a truck you look
old enough it doesn't matter i knew how
to drive a truck if i was driving the
diesel but you know they'd be in the
seat and i just downshifting is
impossible i don't give a [ __ ] how old
you are i can't do this [ __ ] and
everyone's just a hard worker my mom is
a hard-ass worker that other side i come
from a work ethic everyone every single
person my sister's a hard ass worker
everybody you know you want to work
smart too
that's the thing they're all rich as
[ __ ] now it's good dude yeah they're all
just let's start this company in this
company so when i'm sleeping i'm making
money
good job see that's smart so we have to
do it my grandma and then live like
i grew up poor i said yeah but my
grandma's [ __ ] millionaire so good
but we never got that money because that
was my dad's mom and they were like nope
we ain't giving her money yeah so i grew
up just poor
i think cardi b was talking about that
with her with her son or son she goes
i'll buy my son an apartment
that's it he's got to find his own way
you know i was like damn i think a
little different that's the jackie chan
method jackie chan gives his kids
nothing really dude he his son got
caught with a grow house in china which
is a death it's an offense it's a
death penalty offense wheat is illegal
there son got caught with a grow
operation what happened to his son he
got him off and he gives him nothing
that's it he didn't go to jail and he
gets nothing jackie chan says i made my
own money my kids can make their own
money he's [ __ ] 300 mil deep what a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what a ticket rumble in the bronx money
give him a little bit of the rumble in
the bronx money man
give him some russia he's hardcore dude
he's smart though he's smart his son's
[ __ ] up but maybe
he was growing weak because he has no
[ __ ] money and all his friends are
billionaires
there is a handicap to wealth the the
see the great irony of life is i know
some people with some real
the
money
the biggest challenge is instilling a
work ethic and desire in your kid like
you know it's hard not to create a soft
kid when they've got nothing to worry
about man
i mean i don't know i i mean i think i
want to stop like
you don't want no money but like i told
mario like i want my kids to be the most
spoiled kids ever and be awesome and not
pieces of [ __ ] because i basically
raised my little brother my little bird
17
might be one of the coolest people i've
ever met he's such a [ __ ] cool ass i
can't wait he's 18 so i can just be my
friend now that's so cool he's my little
brother he's [ __ ] cool wow
but as even as a baby like hey
don't act like a [ __ ] dick i wouldn't
cuss but like don't do that why because
this this and that and that guy did that
what my mom was doing except i'm giving
real lessons
he's 30 in his head that's so cool
some people are old souls man they are
aren't they yeah some people are just
old they just get it they just get it
right away my daughter at 13 just gets a
lot of stuff like i have conversations
with her i'm like how do you know this
much
but she's you know she's just interested
in school and story i'm just different
once you're interested in things that
aren't shown to you every day like i
didn't listen to mainstream music until
i was like 20. right because i'm on the
bus just
all these people i don't think are smart
or cool are loving this song i got to
get away from whatever this is or all
you following trends as a kid means
you're just that kid so when i was a kid
get made fun of my first album was
please please me and i was like so hyped
on it that was my [ __ ] i was in the
doo-wop i was like 14.
and i got made fun of him every day
huh you're saying
um no i i have some stuff i never worked
on but i i like it yeah i like it but my
grandpa he um
it was ferris bueller when he started
singing twisted shout out can't believe
you hit me with these songs these these
movies oh why i wouldn't ferris bueller
was a seminal movie for me it's i
changed my life because that movie you
want to be cooler and don't that's why i
wanted to stop and smell the [ __ ]
roses he's cool he was ch running home
he didn't hate me he didn't understand
he did what
like he just said i'm gonna do that's a
he he's like school doesn't make sense
to me right now and i'm gonna live
dangerously i'm gonna live dangerously
die young and leave a good looking
corpse it's like that idea right like my
life i'm gonna turn my life into a
circus nietzsche said that too he's like
you can live safe and play by the rules
or you can live dangerously
and
some people get that early like i'm not
getting that much trouble when i was a
kid my mom would punch me in the face so
i didn't do no i was cautious right but
ferris bueller's jumping on stage in the
middle of the [ __ ] chicago taking the
mic
that to me when he started singing
twists and shout out i went who sings
that song yeah my girl's always the
beatles yep that was my first album i
ever got is that dude you got a great
movie like
you movies and [ __ ] that's all yeah
that's all i grew up you're hitting me
with like old time
it's fun [ __ ] though man it's it's
it's [ __ ] ferris bueller i love that
it's sarah's bueller dude he is the
coolest kid that's so cool started
skating because of bart simpson he was
cool right i feel like music that music
because ferris bueller was singing it
yeah you know yeah and plus my mom was
that's one thing she did do good was
hey sit down i'm not gonna watch it but
this is a good movie and i'd watch that
movie right so watching these movies as
a six-year-old like
goodfellas like i said or godfathers and
casino you're trying to figure out like
you see the personality trait oh that
girl she's a piece of [ __ ] and at the
end yeah she [ __ ] died and screwed
him over you could tell joe pisses a
piece of [ __ ] right and there's robert
de niro the good and
you start j you you learn humans
watching movies so i was watching all
these dramatic ass oscar movies
and i that's how i thought right you
know it molds people so when they're
watching yo gabba gabba all [ __ ] day
they're gonna cry at the store yeah
yeah you know that's how i see it it's
great dude you've got these references
that are my generation yeah um
you should have seen tommy chong like
what the [ __ ] i love oh he's like linda
ronstadt you know who this is like
yes continue
he was all hyped up i think he was more
hype like
you know what the [ __ ] but you know that
but that that [ __ ] that that does stand
the test of time you have good taste
because you know the difference like
that's the difference yeah bro like you
know the difference between [ __ ]
trash pop art and real art
great story and [ __ ] that's that
says a lot about you that's that's not
easy dude
that's not it's not that common it's not
like how many people do you mean it's
like they're like i love the i'm like a
[ __ ] off with that yeah so when i that's
why i asked you see little big man [ __ ]
yes thank you you've seen world
according to garp
i've read the book as well oh not only
that i got one better for you john
irving the writer was my wrestling coach
in high school
culinary he wrote that and
robert was a wrestler in that john
irving he wrote a movie about a wrestler
john irving wrote the book
the world according to garp it was
turned into a movie
and john irving was my uh r wrestling
coach
and oh by the way colin irving is in
that movie
as a wrestler in the locker room and
yeah that's why i really want to start
wrestling because my dad wrestled and
world and going to garber there you go
williams wrestles thanks i want to
wrestle great [ __ ] movie john
lithgow's a chick great movie [ __ ]
movie dude i wanna go home watch that
movie now that's how good it is when i
was a kid dirty 30. what up and now you
think what am i gonna be when i'm 30.
and when i turn 30 i woke up and thought
of that line and john irving himself was
a hell of a wrestling nationally ranked
wow that's just so [ __ ] insane genius
writer one of the great american writers
[ __ ] he's he wrote that and he's the
wrestler yes dude he's a phenomenal he's
phenomenal you really took wrestling
series yeah i i i did won 35s
uh well that's a good one i i was yes i
was 138 my senior year yes i was
thinking yeah and then i was 135 in
sixth grade i was gonna go to college
wrestle
i think it was 141 what about oh you
took it serious like that good [ __ ] yeah
i love that that's awesome i did it for
three years but i was always heavy so i
was a sixth grader wrestling eighth
graders my only regret is not wrestling
in college
really
yeah i think it's one thing like i quit
football and i have dreams you know what
dude my regret is i didn't become a
dancer like a great dancer and i didn't
learn how to play the piano and sing
yeah that's my regret but then if i
could do that i'd probably be like wish
i could throw a punch and russell
that's good you're always evolving
i guess
but but don't do you ever think about
like if you go back
what would you tell yourself right now
if you're if you can go back and see
yourself see thomas at 15 years old what
would you say to him don't worry you're
not going to be poor forever that's the
same thing i was going to say [ __ ]
relax don't trip you just keep working
like you're working that's it uh it's
interesting that's it everything else is
fine like case try to stay in shape
don't you're not going to be poor
forever and that's it because what if
you didn't know that like what if i
didn't and that's why i always work so
[ __ ] oh yeah so then and even now
though it's like i'm not rich
nobody in my family has a house for me
that's like you know i want to get like
even my cousins like don't worry man i
got you how much is it i gotcha yeah
that's that's the that's a great feeling
oh i just
i just won't buy my dad's challenger and
give it to him because he wrecked his
challenger when my mom was pregnant with
me he like just told this sick ass
challenge just one picture of it
and i would like to buy that back and
give it to him yeah [ __ ] like that
just little things but i mean there's
nothing better than that no
there's a point nothing better than that
and i want to have a really crazy house
where i go this is my [ __ ] house
yeah that's it yeah that's it yeah if i
spill something go
i'll get it cleaned it's okay i don't
it's not the end of the [ __ ] world
yeah you can get to a point where you
don't look at price tags um i want to
pay my bills and not look at my balance
yeah that's another goal for me i did
that last month which really made me
[ __ ] hyped i paid the bills and went
don't trip i just kept going my day
that's a good thing made me happy as
[ __ ]
yeah my buddy my buddy made more money
than god and we he took me out to lunch
and we had crazy wine and caviar
and the bill came and i looked at it it
was 4 800 bucks
400 bucks he didn't look at the check he
just paid it he just went like that
yeah like i was telling you in my black
market he didn't see he did the tip no
the tip was included
the guy goes yeah he goes to secluded
and he just goes thanks and he just went
he was talking and i go
did you look at that no they got it
right do you see how much that is and he
looks like he is here i go is it what is
that to you is that 48 cents to you i go
to that's 40. i guess that's 4.80 and he
goes a little more than that i mean a
little less than that yeah because it's
maybe he goes he goes a little less than
that he goes maybe a lot less
and i was like if you tell me that's 48
cents to you like i'm gonna lose my
money that's that's how much money he
has that's [ __ ] great so everything
is free i know one person like that
where it's like yeah what'd you just
[ __ ] say you can get to a point i got
to a point where like i i didn't have to
worry like you know not that crazy but
you could it's not that hard to get to a
point where you can go out to dinner and
eat whatever you want and
go to buy clothing and you know whatever
it is where you can you can get that
kind of nicer car and you don't really
worry about it yeah but then i don't
know i just even if i was a billionaire
i'm not going to be spending ten
thousand dollars on lunch it's just not
for no dude i have a friend that the
only reason he did that is i
like he's a
i love really good wine
but you know you're gonna spend a
fortune so and then i love caviar so we
did this crazy they had this whole thing
oh god i was like all right well i'm not
paying for that salt guy that does
assault and expensive that [ __ ]
my friend spent 30 [ __ ] thought did i
tell you him and his friend spent 30
[ __ ] thousand dollars how was it it
was okay
it was okay 30 grand 30 bands 30 it was
29 something 30 000
14 of it was just shots he's like we
didn't know there were 70 [ __ ]
dollars a shot but they don't care
they're like yeah here
but they're all [ __ ] black market
guys so they're like cash where else am
i going to spend it
just criminals yeah where the [ __ ] else
would but you would never know they just
look like family men with nice houses
and that do a good job
that's why they're my friends i wouldn't
associate myself with that
but it's just
it makes me smile
because i know when they were broke and
it's like i'm so [ __ ] happy for you
dude yeah like you can't buy a house but
[ __ ] awesome 30k
30. okay well i mean it's my it's my
friend he
buys a million dollar car and [ __ ] it's
a little excessive
but it's that's a cool it's cool to look
at bugattis
yeah the cullinans and this and all that
crazy [ __ ] i'm just not i have the money
i got i'm fixing up my old car yeah it's
when i get rich are you a car guy
no me neither not at all i don't know
how they i don't know everybody's a
mechanic in my family and they try to
make me do it and i went [ __ ] this
and i never got back under the truck
i hate it i'll drop it off fix it for me
thanks i'll try like i said armageddon
dude i can't fix anything i'm gonna walk
everywhere armageddon
i [ __ ] hate it i can't do anything my
girl my girl can do [ __ ] rosie my i had
i had my car i bought this prius for
somebody and um
and and it had the bumper had fallen off
and i was like i gotta take it in she
goes
jesus she gets on her back and [ __ ]
ties it up i was like oh yes rosie's
she's the mechanic her dad's that she's
liked it so she can do all the car [ __ ]
that i don't know how what the [ __ ] is
going on so don't you have to do that
first goal
yeah i guess so thank you you should
have told me that before we get started
yeah i [ __ ] hate it man i can't do it
but i'll drive them
i have an old-school car a new car
that's all i need yeah me too yeah i
don't like [ __ ] just take take me
where i gotta go yeah but safely and
fast please
i mean i've never really gone fast until
recently it's pretty fun yeah i didn't
realize how fun it was what are you
driving uh
the mercedes it's fantastic
i didn't know about the tesla yet no i
heard it as fast as [ __ ] though go ahead
and get yourself involved in that
once you're getting that it's that fast
yeah i heard like rocket launchers
logan rogan was always dissing my tesla
and i was dissing electric cars and
and then elon musk did his podcast and
then elon musk i think then he bought
that or maybe elon gave it to him i
don't know is that ludicrous package the
one with the that goes 2.06 in two point
like one seconds or something the one
elon drives
he called me he goes all of the cars are
stupid
it doesn't make any sense how fast it is
i was like wow there you go yeah i'm
good i haven't gotten the lambos yet
they all have them like
i'll watch you bro yeah no unless you
want me to drive it right i don't trust
people driving me it scares me yeah it's
like holding a knife to my neck yeah i'm
like yo you have my life in your hands
[ __ ] you
i can't do i smell like planes i don't
get in boats i don't like trains
i don't like boats at all i don't get in
the water get the [ __ ] you want me to be
out in the middle of the ocean yeah
knows me he
they he [ __ ] sails across the
atlantic and pacific and gets caught in
storms in a little [ __ ] tales but get
the [ __ ]
volunteer here no you're not gonna catch
me and you're and you gotta tie yourself
to the ghetto so you don't fall off the
boat and you gotta just ride the storm
out do i in the middle of the the pitch
black ocean could there be anything
scary and you're a cork i get enough
[ __ ] imagine working your whole life
waking up going to school doing all this
to die in the [ __ ] ocean oh god
as i'm drowning and you you hit like
some debris and you got a hole and
you're trying to plug it up and it's
nighttime you can't see and the water's
freezing and you know there are monsters
waiting for you monsters yeah dude
you're in the middle of the ocean
monsters and you're gonna die a thirst
and if sharks don't get you and they
will
yeah you're gonna die surrounded by
water thirst or that sun's gonna be
beating down on your stupid face you
ever seen cabin boy
no no chris elliott in the 90s oh i did
remember kevin i can't believe you
[ __ ] know but do you remember when
he's dying from starting from yeah i did
that
yes
my brain just broke
but uh no i always compare the ocean is
ready let's go to griffith park but
there's a chance there's a lion
yeah like yeah okay go in the ocean it's
the same [ __ ] thing but you can't
breathe in it yeah and also you can't
breathe and the lion's invisible until
he bites you like [ __ ] you i'm going
home dude
what it's the same things going i was on
a cruise
and i looked out at the ocean at night
and it's
pitch black
you could be out there in the middle of
that [ __ ]
freezing with those waves
best kisses
because my luck i'm going to live
that's why i told you i don't like i
will not i don't i love the water i
don't like it because i'm going to live
by myself too yep yeah i'm not getting
on your boat this might sink yeah i
can't stand on water pirates might [ __ ]
me up this is the day that the [ __ ]
the monsters decide to storm earth and
i'm out here by my [ __ ] self yeah i
just only put myself in positions i
can't get out of immediately giant great
whites
jellyfish that sting there's a thousand
things that hate you in the ocean
i'm so glad you think giant fish
everyone around me likes like let's go
to the beach like [ __ ] you so i can burn
yeah no so the undertow takes me
somewhere watch out
dude i i did do sometimes i do [ __ ] that
scares me though because i did get on a
surfboard and go out in very rough
weather in
in the atlantic in france and it was
raining
and it was night i did it and it was
nice i did it because i cuz i'm
because i was like and they were like be
careful with riptide and i and i'm not a
good surfer i don't know how to surf and
i did it yeah it was bad i just did it
because it was so uncomfortable and i
was in the middle of it where you're
like why the [ __ ] am i here the waves
would look like they were like i was
like in the himalayas i was like going
up and down
paddle paddle go under now and it's like
ah no that because yeah it [ __ ] me up
it [ __ ] me up can't do that [ __ ] yeah
and i kind of got hurt a little bit and
in the water yeah because the waves were
like hitting and then i got my board
hit the sand as i got went back into the
it was it was [ __ ] up i'm not a i'm
not a sea guy man
nobody i'm not a c
yeah
like and how about the dudes that decide
they're going to kayak down the congo
river i said this the other day and they
wonder why
20-foot crocs are like delicious
you're surprised bro that you're in a
boat that is that a hippo hippos will
100 kill you
if they're bigger than your boat they
will 100
bite you
in your face
this is my territory [ __ ] off i'm gonna
bite you and then you get capsized and
el
el crocodillo
or
he just shows up and kills you anyway
yeah or the tribe people that are like
yo what the [ __ ] are you doing here
exactly
i'm good man in indonesia this guy they
have those boats that i swear to god
you're that you're on you're in the boat
it's a fishing boat crocodile's
everywhere giants and you're in a you're
in a [ __ ] boat and this the water is
right there it's level do you understand
i saw that i saw a video just like that
and guess what dude a [ __ ] giant croc
got this guy and ate him disappeared
just disappeared he took him off the
boat sure did sure did you saw the video
no the guy just disappeared so they knew
it was a croc so they went looking for
the giant croc they knew there was a j
fisherman had seen a crocodile that was
crazy big like like 25 feet like wide
wide like just this table captain hook
crocodile crazy captain hook crocodile
capitan hook crocodile yes
and they go looking and they're shining
a light at night and they see these two
giant eyes that they're good they can
tell that the croc is massive because
the eyes are spread
they're so spread apart they're like a
yard apart
and they go well that's the monster
imagine how big that now now they're in
this swamp land right now watch this
their propeller gets caught up in the
[ __ ]
algae slash weeds
the dude jumps off the boat and gets the
propeller free
at night in that water it's like bro
brave [ __ ] what are you [ __ ]
doing brave ass man get back in the boat
see his generation
that's a generation that's tough parents
dude get in the [ __ ] water anthony
bourdain when he was in the congo river
at night the guy goes okay just jump off
the jump off and then just he jumps into
the river and he was like what are you
afraid of because he crocs he goes i
don't blame you the guy just jumped off
had to tie the boat up you know you jump
in the water and you just run get the at
night dude a croc will grab you and i'll
see you later you're gone see you later
yeah and i saw anaconda there's bugs and
i saw anaconda
that's a myth actually okay well my mind
is real i agree
yeah have you seen the video in the
congo of the anaconda they caught those
villagers they made that trap
they made like a long tube trap and they
caught like a 60-foot [ __ ] snake i
saw it the skin hold up what you're
talking about no where they've caught a
live snake they trap like half of its
front body well the congo is no joke
it's not an anaconda those are in south
america it must be some a different kind
of i mean the snake is from here congo
has got crazy [ __ ] there okay it's a
video of them catching
a gigan no in the water i mean it is
[ __ ] frightening
yeah
wow you know what's crazy didn't even
land a joint
i lost in questions
dude yeah lots of conversations it's a
great conversator it worked do you smoke
weed at all i do but i have to drive and
take this home and smoke it later i will
is it good weed it's [ __ ] strong
really
go to sleep with that girl will smoke
all of this it's super super strong oh
that's damn yes
i'll get so high
for sure it i just i i'm that smells
good
it's strong yeah it's uh just og i've
been smoking for five years straight
really could you smoke this whole joint
in function
yeah yeah
usually smoked three four of those on
the episode is that true and they're
usually way fatter yeah we we've done
some crazy [ __ ] we've rolled the pound
joint half pound joint you can smoke
that much and be fine oh yeah and host
the show i don't know how but my brain
it's just like
oh all the thc [ __ ] gone so so does
the thg is a stimulant for you i smoke
weed as a habit i think now
but i usually smoke like a zip maybe zip
a half a day when i was selling a lot
you smoke today you don't seem high at
all um no i smoked a [ __ ] load of bong
grubs before i got here today yeah you
don't seem high at all
if i smoke ten of those and be cool it's
like coffee yeah do you have uh it's
like water so water you just built a
resistance do you have uh the munchies
when you no doesn't really happen you're
no you're you're a real weed smoker yeah
if i smoke that i will eat
all the food till my tummy burns that's
okay yeah that's okay when i get high
and hungry i go
[ __ ] where have you been like i get like
holy [ __ ] it's been years that's right
you chase that sensation it's like
chasing your first kiss yeah it's weird
like how much do i have smoke just get a
little
literally a memory of what it used to be
like yeah no dude we've done crazy [ __ ]
like the edibles we did 5000 milligrams
at once yeah it [ __ ] me up but it
wasn't like five thousand i'm done i saw
cocaine like that i saw a guy just go
crazy like a crazy fat lime that was
like your heart's gonna stop like point
five like i said we used 2.8 to a gram
like one because we usually go i bet you
i could [ __ ] do it because like with
me i could drink a fish i drink that
bottle and not be shit-faced yeah you
got strong i don't know what it is my
dad and my mom used to smoke meth so
maybe that's what there it
is that true yes my mom was actually a
guest because everybody [ __ ] asked
for it my mom is joe pesci and rosie
perez together like a crazy [ __ ] wild
dude funny though they made a kid that's
really smart that's weird i always
thought like is my memory i have a
photograph of memory that's why i tell
all these stories
i think it's the acid
unlock some [ __ ] when i was made
maybe it has to be maybe he is like a
weird nature verse nurture style
experiment because like
you know you might you look at his mom
like she beats [ __ ] out of them all this
[ __ ] all his
hundreds i know but that goes to show
you how much of it is nature nurture
what what ratio is it it's probably both
but man have you got a spirit like my
father's 81 and my sister was like the
[ __ ] doesn't eat well he's fat
and he's 81 and he's like he but his
life force is so strong plays he he
argues he's still got political points
of view plays tennis every day i mean
plays golf every day and my sister was
like if his heart could it would come
out of his body and slap him across the
face and it was so true but you know the
dude is just his his
spirit it's what it is like i said my
grandma's 88 and all my uncles are still
[ __ ] scared of him and he's this
[ __ ] big yeah man he's just a scary
[ __ ] he still works every day
all day breaking [ __ ] he's kind of big
it's [ __ ] 88 it's just how you live
like bear down yeah but like you're
saying it's like a nature nerd well when
i was three i looked at my mom my dad
beating the [ __ ] out of each other i
went
this is not fun i don't want to do that
i definitely don't want to be these
funny guys funny how sometimes the best
thing you can do for your kids is set a
bad example so that they decide to be
exactly if your kid's not a dumbass you
can do the right thing in life out of
fear though but it works yes out of fear
because my mom i was never in a gang
it's a certain type of person man like i
said not everybody was watching [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] yeah maybe your parents would
have destroyed somebody weaker or more
fragile i don't know something
around that nothing has changed since
i've been alive i've been thinking like
this since i can remember my earliest
memory was getting a [ __ ]
sink
bath remember like when you watch babies
in the sink wow and that my
great-grandma died when i was two or a
year and a half so i [ __ ] remember
that i remember her damn it's the acid
it's your brain fasted it truly is it's
like weed is a way you self-medicate
somehow like what would your brain be
without it i just smoked a lot of weed
because i was so poor when i was a kid
before i started selling away like oh my
god we got 10 bucks let's [ __ ] get a
blunt of you know jerry so you were
smoking weed when you were really young
yeah like 13-ish wow around there i
started smoking weed and then all my
grades stopped being ape i was the
master of the year uh all that [ __ ] yeah
i used to be anti-drug because i was all
about football and getting buff as [ __ ]
and reggie white was the coolest guy and
yeah you know and then i got introduced
to drugs is he he's not when did he
retire reggie white retired i want to
say 2002 and he passed away like 2004.
five oh reggie white i thought you got
reggie bush oh no he was i'm five years
older than i am
reggie white man oh i got his little
toys in my my [ __ ] right now and brett
favre 15 seasons oh what a beast
he was so young 43 yeah he was so young
wow did he die suicide or a heart attack
he just passed away one day
a big giant smile and a man and just
died killer super sad it's like the
michael clark duncan thing he's just too
[ __ ] big
think about it i i mean i can't imagine
being six six six a that'd be [ __ ]
badass but yeah bro
if you don't get your heart checked too
yep that's why i got all this [ __ ]
i'm trying now good i'm not [ __ ]
older going well i'm done you can do it
dude oh i'm on it i'm already literally
i already got it back i can ready like
you know your brain clicks yeah i'm
already back so i'm looking at that like
i could do that [ __ ] all at once and
he's inspiring
[ __ ] people out there too yeah because
there's a lot of people that don't do
stuff that follow our like you know what
get up yeah man just get up well i i
think
you know you a lot of times 20 minutes
literally set a timer no more than that
start there i promise you
do 20 minutes do 20 minutes just you
don't need more than that that's true i
got the personal trainer in three
minutes i'm like
[ __ ]
you know what do 10 minutes at first if
you literally can't just just do it lift
any kind of weight for 10 minutes do
something yeah and cardio is cool but i
think wait you have to do it i'm not a
fan of cardio you have to i like the
boxing [ __ ] in some way yeah
i feel like if you can't lift up the
weights but you can run deadlifts
deadlift bench
deadlifts fun but pull ups and dips you
know i mean you hit the [ __ ] pull-ups
like they weren't [ __ ] i gotta get on
that yeah i gotta get on there
but now like my arms and [ __ ] like i get
like you know i have to warm up
that's fine have you seen that [ __ ]
85 year old bodybuilder from the
philippines no that falls rocked
i mean uh bolo young bruce lee [ __ ]
put it in 85 steroids for real bro he's
just like four five four six little said
his name no just put in a
super old
asian bodybuilder you're gonna be
shocked he might even be older than 80.
i saw the little story on him i mean he
is he's bolo young
yeah i love that [ __ ] oh he's 70 in that
one works out at gold's gym
in venice and i've seen him many times
i can't believe you know who bolo is
oh
dream what's this dude
um no definitely not the guy was huge
this guy's really big that guy's 70. and
that's that's look at that wait a minute
[ __ ] out for being seven are you kidding
me
one of these old men i'm telling you is
like he was like 80 to 90 years old and
he was so [ __ ] buff it might be that
bottom left
see that old man
look at this old man
he's the [ __ ] guy he is rocked out
every old dude i see that's like in a
park is shredded off because they the
body because they're tired of being in
the house with their family like you
almost get buffed by myself it's my new
routine
you just keep trying and consistency
yeah so you're into the bruce lee i'm
assuming
yeah
the dragon enter the dragon return of
the dragon chinese connection
it confused me when the chinese names
were different from the american
versions but they're the same movie i
just watched senator dragon again it's
so good man
you know i i love it remember those two
well you ain't going
two racist random cops just pull up on
his ass in the alley yeah you ain't
going no way
yeah he's got a karate student
tim kelly he's got a [ __ ] karate suit
on he's gonna beat the [ __ ] out of you
so [ __ ] awesome oh i [ __ ] love
that movie so much and i feel like
jackie chan really should have been like
you know what every base of every
premise of a movie is just a bruce lee
booth well he did he said he he goes
he's in another dragon i want to do he
said i watch bruce lee and he goes i'm
going to be the comedic bruce lee i'm
going to punch and hurt my hand like ah
and that and it was just he did a good
job at it because he is the community
bruce lee yes dude his own stunts have
you ever seen that he entered the dragon
yeah no was he in it yeah he's the guy
that he's holding by the neck when this
when he drops the black snakes
i didn't know it was just jackson he's
holding him like this and he's got like
a little chopped haircut and he's like a
17 year old jackie chan he's he's the
one that he grips and he throws jackie
chan
yeah look it up google it when you get
home after you smoke that joint go what
the [ __ ]
listen to jackie chan's story about that
day he accidentally got kicked in the
face by bruce lee and he's like he
didn't say nothing and as soon as he
said cut he's just oh my god i'm so
sorry i'm sorry trying to fix him and
chicks he's like i just started blushing
i was bleeding so as soon as he did i
just pretended to be more hurt so bruce
lee could you know help me
he's like i was fanning out as a little
boy damn dude he came up in the circus
jackie chan chinese circus yeah i didn't
know that he was training acrobatics and
all that [ __ ] makes [ __ ] sense dude
makes sense what a [ __ ] athlete oh
jackie chan give some money to your kids
jackie chan i know jackie come on man
bro give me some money i want to be one
of your kids yeah i'll [ __ ] do a
stunt i'll i'll fall for a million
dollars you wiped out on the skateboard
not too long ago that was for free yeah
hey [ __ ] i'm good
um
dude
thanks for being here thanks for having
me brother thanks for coming i mean
oh [ __ ] we're two hours in damn damn
that did not feel like [ __ ] two hours
at all no i didn't
all right this is great thank you for
thank you for coming thank you for
having me um
just as a movie kitten and as tv kid i'm
just so stoked thank you so much i just
it's all replaying in my head i
appreciate you man appreciate you guys
uh where can everybody find you on
social media you know what um
you can find i'm gonna be in buffalo if
you're in buffalo marty's our hometown
buffalo i knew what was coming
[Music]
helium september 9th 10th and 11th and
then the 25th to the 27th i'll be in
denver at comedy works the best one of
the best clubs in the country and then
if you're from chicago i'll be in
schaumburg september 30th october 1
october 2 at the schomburg improv
and then um you can find me i get i do
on rockfin i do conspiracy social club
with sam tripoli fighter and a kid yeah
you told me about that
yep he's [ __ ] hilarious he he hits me
with conspiracies and i try to debunk
them and all we do is argue it's like
wwe all we [ __ ] do is argue but it's
got a good fight it's so stupid
so so that's conspiracy social club i
think it's like so it's on rockfin and
then um
i don't know i think i'm gonna do it on
patreon i think i'm gonna do uh colin
kaelin yeah i'm gonna have people come
in and ask me questions you gotta get
the old school phone
dude how great would that be right i
gotta get it i gotta do it it's not a
rotary one [ __ ] i will bro i swear to
god i'm gonna do that this is fun man i
swear to god i'm gonna do that [ __ ] uh
cricket offers the brick phone the cell
phone you can get an old phone inside
the brick phone come on bro i saw
somebody with you they go hey how the
[ __ ] you caught you talking on this
[ __ ] what network he's like it's
[ __ ] cricket
ah bro i'm doing it all right i might
get a shitty service just to get that
[ __ ] something like that it's so fun
i love that [ __ ] and i one thing i will
say yeah for people that are calling in
i think you just an idea yeah say you're
there just taking a call and then you
have will sasso come in and impersonate
so today i have arnold schwarzenegger
he's co-hosting with me such a good idea
dude right and the whole time getting
him going like holy [ __ ] it's arnold
schwarzenegger at the end
it's just [ __ ] not that's such a good
idea i'm gonna have different i'll have
ric flair i'll have all kinds of
different people it could be so many
people you see what i'm saying come on
in and talk do you drunk kenny rogers
again
such a good idea just have every so
often like so today my my co-host but
they don't [ __ ] know it's not done
yet i think it's a great idea do it
do it all right thank you so much thank
you for coming thank you we're gonna get
you out of here um guys everybody thank
you so much for watching this has been
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast have a dope ass day
thanks man
that was fun
cleanest outro ever i usually [ __ ] it up
40 times thank you brother that was
awesome thank you oh man wow i can't
believe i didn't like this [ __ ] joy
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]